in the button let me see if it's a
ruling start and I am waiting oh I see
stream elf uh-oh
Steven got it I guess that's good and we
are live welcome to the iron Lords
podcast and the Lords of gaming dotnet
episode number 126 and it's another
glorious Sunday we're back at the
roundtable on the Lord's Day I'm very
excited about our special guest and
we've got Link's Awakening to
PlayStation v SKUs III evolution and
Microsoft hiding numbers to discuss so
we go get right into it I want to
introduce the Lord whom I had the
pleasure of meeting in the flesh at
Bethesda e3 2019 now on is this law one
of the most multifaceted content
creators in the game but he also
provides insightful motivation for our
dreams that may yet reside in another
castle introducing they're creating host
of the n64 Josh twitch YouTube website
and Nintendo Power cast the author of
the inspiring book another castle and
Lords grab your power glove because
we're partying with the rock star and
lead singer from until today now mister
soon laughs of Seattle and making his
debut into the realm of the Lord's mom
made Lord n64 Josh how you doing sir
that was the best introduction that you
said I carry him around in my bookbag
yeah we might have to turn your levels
up a little bit Josh you've got low
Kraig that oh we gotta get that album
sound sir yeah yeah there we go
but what's good on that is that better a
little bit all right cool cool cool
we're figured out we figured out but
otherwise what's going on man so you
doing a twitch stream we had Link's
Awakening going
change how's that sound
much better oh you in the building baby
let's go yeah talk to Google Hangouts
they default it to my on like my oh yeah
yeah sorry about that
no so good baby now you live now we got
the album that's that's what I'm talking
about that I'm very open to blaming
Google Hangouts at this point
oh cool so uh yeah doing great I've been
like I've been doing a lot of stuff
going behind the scenes like that's like
really really exciting stuff nice but
it's been like draining me like i'm i've
been putting all my creative juices into
this stuff that i'm that i'm working
towards
okay so so this weekend has been like
hey i'm gonna take a me weekend nice and
that means i'm gonna stream for way
longer than i do a weekend is still me
creating cuz that's just the way I am
but they would though
yeah Link's Awakening Call of Duty beta
like the goose can't why but oh you got
the goose train I will talk about we're
gonna talk about that that Jays boat
yeah I got it I haven't I haven't
started playing yet Lynx awaking he's
got it's got its claws in me and how
they Call of Duty is so good I wish it
had its claws in me so Call of Duty's
good but I've seen the cross play going
everybody have a fun out here oh dude I
mean I'm a shooter guy that's like my
roots are like goldeneye perfect dark
that kind of stuff that's a you know
that's where I fell in love shooters and
I mean halos what where my love is that
as far as when it comes to shooters but
I played a lot of modern warfare and
martin warfare - back in the day and i
have never touched black ops ive never
played a black ops game and so when this
was when I knew this beta was dropping
I'm like you know what it's time sound
I've been playing a little gears 5 also
just nice you know I had to take it
I had Nintendo's just falling a little
short in the shooter yeah they gotta
shoot a game together yeah I agree
overwatch is coming let's uh
so no little doubt very good to have you
in the realm I know like I said we got a
chance to meet back then a shout to Lord
go supreme who's with me
I think we met at the Podesta joint you
know yeah yeah it was dope just chopping
it talked gays told you go keep my word
have you been around so glad to have you
brother yeah I'm glad to be here thank
you so much you already know and you
already know we got the Four Horsemen of
gaming those original Lords of the room
here at the round table
my co-host with the co most my brother
from another mother the difficult game
conqueror Lord of reviews and the how of
the young wolf not me
Lord addict how you doing sir doing
pretty good let me meet the podcast I
don't like hearing myself talk you're
doing pretty good unfortunately I know
it might be 1107 to some of you people
but it might as well be 707 to me go
take me better to trust this energy he's
sound all right ready look look man I I
am raising my voice upon part I'm being
a fraud right now let's be good okay
which we play I've been playing
Borderlands pretty much all I'm done
with it so it's probably gonna go oh
come on now it's a good game
and I weighed over quick
what would over quit the pitcher lug
Randy Pitchford lovely he was talking
this office off oh no no listen I love
that guy
I think if I'm doing something and he's
my CEO he's backing me 100% I know he
got my back that's one thing I don't
worry about but I believe they pushed
that game up just a little tad bit early
I don't think it has anything to do with
him per se um you know honestly probably
the board room something like that you
know stuff that we talked about so you
know but from what I hear I'm not
purchasing you know I'm a game past dude
so whenever a drop in game past I'll
give my thoughts on it is that your your
your key moment to everything now I'm
gonna tell you why it's gonna stay my
moment no there's not borderland slander
going on literally he just said what's
wrong with the gauge lowball you hate
early I love it let's go as long as you
purchase oh you like it I'll wait for it
to get the game past when it patched up
no doubt so that's good at it pretty
much Borderlands I've been playing
Phoenix point with that game just it's
so intense it's it's taking a little bit
but I mean yeah that's it a lot of Final
Fantasy 8 on the switch I like - I did
be a lot of switch slam though on this
podcast so what I hear that I got to get
excited clowning on stuff that everyone
clowns artists slam we talked about how
the wicker port looks we're slightly
I'll be good I'll be quick the bus yeah
good whatever anyway
and of course returning we have our most
technical gaming Lord go solo gamer who
lives with a single player Selfridge
experience and also the sastra Thomas
mr. Flom profile Illuminati and lore
patreon of the iron bank mommy
Lord sovereign are you doing sir very
good good morning as Madea would say
hello good day back so I was good over
but beat back sir I'm also frauding I'm
totally under the table but you know you
got to do it I said no what it's 1:30
a.m.
should I play some gears did I go to bed
okay one second so okay we have a super
Chester we have blue King shout out to
my man dizzy with much love I'm gonna
read you know Chet these are old King
stops King stalling you know you know
dizzy you know what you may be I think
you're not on today actually busy I
think you lose you sir what I want you
to do this dizzy I want you to have your
credit card ready be a petty back to
solve what you've been playing sir at
1:30 in the morning yeah like I said I
had to play some gears man I haven't had
a chance to touch it at all I'm still in
act 1 but on
so yesterday I got to the part where I I
guess you you think you're about to get
extracted and then the swarm comes and
then this woman's basically just the the
the villains from the matrix but that
scene immediately after that that cuts
me wow man like the whole screen is
drenched in like blood literally fire
like the colours the HDR popping in that
scene in particular roles
asking well what's funny is there's like
a scene towards the end the game with
mark is that like everyone is just crack
and I'm sure you guys those boilers we
got it I got the I don't know yet
spoiling well yeah I'll leave it at that
you're just absolutely gorgeous but um
besides that man out of nostalgia man I
had to I had to go and pick up that
Genesis mini man I had not I'm not gonna
pre-ordered anything I was like oh my
goodness and then the last week like I'm
hearing such great things about I'm like
you know what this is one of my all-time
great consoles like you know everybody
has a story associated with their
console absolutely in whatever the case
may be so from the Genesis for me it's a
funny story because it was the first one
I ever purchased on my own and I'm
alright with my summer work money I used
to working my dad right oh I remember
that I had to spend my whole check to
get it right why what so that my dad
agreed to pay for my my anybody who's
old enough remember tokens yeah train
tokens so has to pay for my tokens for
the following weekend out pay him back
but I would use my whole check to get
the Genesis oh it was funny because we
went to purchase it at the Wiz the way
to win a big TV and it had a friend I
said rise from your grave easy one
please the other thing wasn't my dad
liked to torture me a little bit so we
got out that Friday one o'clock in the
summers that has his job they used to
get out at 1 o'clock right now we're
gonna stop by and hang out with friends
a little bit rather than take me home
which is like five blocks away hello
you had me chill there with him for like
three four hours why staring at the box
in the car like please get it it's a
beautiful it's actually such a fantastic
love letter um the games the way they
set up the way the Japanese thing
okay you know they have the whole they
have this yeah and they have the
cartridge so yeah yeah yeah you know
it's not functional but the visual of it
[Music]
yeah it's not give it a good sonic
slammer and of course we have the
Incredible Hulk of this ak8 the XS game
move the lord of combat sports king of
the statutes who demands nothing less
than that premium experience it is the
leader of the fraud alert movement who
love it like a guy you do exert all you
dudes out there talking about that Gears
of War multiplayer is fire young fraud
alert teef it is the worst thing that
I've played a lot of you all that I
gotta be dealt is to put a turret down I
am sick and tired of that you know I
went to the box I'm gonna see you yo wow
I can only just pick up barriers oh
that's not your specialty I want to get
into this yo monkey I play with wheelies
I swear I hate slam I guess right this
land is my slander what you're playing
horde I'm pretty sure I could play I
made it up to level 50 something okay
don't they tell me yo I was so pissed
off mmm-hmm didn't horde mode for like
40 and up yes I gotta be hard as play
right with my versus the computer right
yeah that's like age so we playing it
right so all the people in this 40
enough yeah you right so check so I'm
putting down the turrets we get anything
popping and monkey telling me okay so
this is this what you do he said but I
want to shoot I wanna kill he said oh
well does is he runs around he repaired
does the repair
everybody's a spotless cake so they
telling me I'm running around with a
ratchet down and I'll be down I'll beat
your looking like that name of the
pissed off dude
you sit there repairing that berry just
hate the world
I don't want to do kind of a class bag
just fellas not for you this is what I
did right I turn I turn my status off
stop playing with them right now you
know what happened to me so I'll turn my
status off and I'm going to start
playing dead cells and I was playing in
all the great games that came out in
game guys well you are so crazy
Danny press they dropped against five
right so people got the game passed and
they got the gas fire for free so we
thought that'd be it for the month the
the Boom Bang in games yeah no sir
that was not to be they release for more
games inside game pass yeah that blood
stain that Jeff Lewis listen the blood
stain which I laughed that you guys so
hard because y'all went out and spending
our hardcore 60s which version and I
paid your $14 actually I didn't paint 14
Devils to pay $40 for the ultimate I got
at game and everything else in the
superior version you know what I said I
don't need to buy games no more my facts
here in game pass play all joke I wanted
to play and I don't have to buy then Jim
funny that you said actually I was
talking to Laura Klock you know a couple
of days ago and I was like you know you
can literally just buy an xbox and play
just game pass games and besides that
like occasional Call of Duty if you like
that game or like the two K's as I mean
you can literally be okay with that yes
they put they don't be put in just like
games they put games that come out there
like 2 or 3 months ago and there's all a
lot of times if you're just patient like
King is talking about and you don't jump
the trigger on the release I feel like I
get a metro or ass I mean you know and
that's I like Kings talk about keep
talking about doing that every game you
don't got to do that if you want to play
a game no plague if you're patient the
mites every
listen addict I wanted to buy Metro
something happened and I didn't get it
and it slipped through the cracks
boom it's going game past playing it I
didn't get dead cells cuz I'm not paying
for those 16-bit looking games but you
know what happened it came on game pass
and it's amazing I would love to see you
stream that game it's so much fun you
know i was so i rage quit the other day
i ran out of my house i swear to god i
ran on miles
i had everything on my character my
health ball was amazing
and all the stuff what happens you with
the break [ __ ] you like kept breaking it
here you went outside of broke yeah
listen listen is a is a little box right
is a little curse box
my stupid behind is a hand in the curse
box right because i was like okay a
second I saw chess chess in a minute you
don't like you and you gotta kill 10
people so we can lift the curse
wow dude I was sweating bullets for 10
minutes running around trying to kill 10
people I have one person left
I shot he threw a grenade he hit me and
killed me yo I want to toss the got my
stuff and wait for nice game is mainly
about memorizing like monster patterns
because you have to fight them so many
times you have to restart the game so
many times says vidiq a yes no doubt so
cover and I wanted to let him know he
was 100% right about dead cell probably
being in one of the games of the year to
be honest with you the gameplay it's
it's amazing in the simplicity but the
what you can do inside like you can
level up the arm the weapons you can
change your perks the the stuff that you
can do within that game and they thought
about it all the way through and is
randomly generated
it's um it's it's amazing it's a me
literally I'm a great thing not to
mention that was that a game there
wouldn't it that was the game that the
reviewers stole that review from yeah
and of course we have to learn of the
cooperative experience and gaming ninja
himself the shinobi lore Cognito
spreading that realness in the ramen ILP
now tell me what you want to hear but
what you need to hear so for me it's
just been a destiny to shout out to
addict sinister Chi Basu we've been
rocking we've been grinding she's
getting a lot of power weapons before
shadow keep getting that gun um sadly
did not cops elders awakening um
couldn't justify just yet hopefully the
next week I'll take that but you know
what I had to get Josh I had to get that
untitled ghost game no goose game is
fire no that goose game is the moat like
this game teaches you how to be a
nuisance there are we really like yes
we're you wanna break down that's called
the goose is untitled goose K shout out
the house house studio bro
that game is like yo Josh did you see
what how you could just terrorize people
with this goose then you like so I had
its downloaded I haven't had a chance to
play but you watch the video and the
goose walks up grabs the farmers
sandwich on the bench and just drops it
in the pond and he's like what what you
gonna do what's up listen dad I like
when they scared in a goose like you
could terrorize it some people don't
like the noise you know it is like
whoever made this stupid git is the
funniest game with the most simple
concept it's just hilarious man shout
out that you know I've never even heard
of this game too recently and then I
just started watching about you I have
to have this man it is hilarious so
shout out to them I've been rocking that
and then home yeah Matt other than that
just so you know I'm sure the same
master training the fire emblem all that
backlog stuff so hopefully I'll get
zelda next week Pournami xbox stuff
brought destiny on pc with that no I'll
go actually do cross save sir I'd be
actual
on xbox so what you do in your game
Pascoe what's up - Oh most of the gates
here's my problem out I impulse buy too
much and a lot of times when it goes
into game pass I already have it so I
should have waited
yes what's funny is he impulse buy halo
wars - the night he came out and never
played and I shouldn't wait I should
they go
so minut that's why I said I'm not gonna
impulse buy just yet oh wait let me get
my backlog together and then uh you know
sound rock out but yeah that's been it
for me but God we got to what the Lord's
have been playing I want to start off
with Lord n64 Josh his video game system
history his journey as an author and
recording artist and of course we'll let
him youtube and the Nintendo Power cast
so Lord Joss I start for the beginning
what was the first kind of video game
systems yeah and what got you the game
alright well um I I got started in the
arcades and with the Atari 2600 did not
did not own the 2600 I on a 40-acre farm
my uncle's lived together just in that
like in a mobile home right near the
house I lived in and the neighbor his
older brother had an Atari so I'd go to
my uncle's mm-hmm grab like like like
Phoenix or pitfall and then we go to the
neighbor's house and play until his mom
kicked us out right that's that's right
that's where it got started
you know those arcades playing punch-out
exhale go guys walk into an arcade
without hearing body blow body blow
uppercut let's go so fast for a little
bit I'm swimming at my grandmother's
house at the lake she lived on the lake
and my my step cousin has this this grey
box in the in the living room mmm with
this with this controller that has two
red buttons and keypad and I was like
what is this right and he he pushes the
power button and the Legend of Zelda
comes up on the screen and there's all
these colors and I'm like this is like
the arcade at home what I got I got a
back you up though
we forget into the key point here the
only one at the time that had the gold
cartridge oh yeah that was the other
thing - it's like glistening in the Sun
like calling what's shiny in the house I
get so we fire that up I get to see my
mom immediately runs in she's like oh we
laugh at this like I couldn't watch the
Smurfs I couldn't watch I had to watch
the vehicle Voltron not the yeah you
can't watch it
Oh Thunder Kass was out for you - I know
Josh I know that struggle Lord's Day
talk I get that brought my step cousin
to the house to have the Nintendo mm-hmm
they they she noticed how much I wanted
this thing and come Christmas morning
here's this giant box it says to the
family and I'm thinking oh sweet it's
like a board game you know whatever well
of course they put it on my lap I ripped
the thing open and my sisters are like
we're out and I'm like
oh my gosh it's happening right I got
Mario duck hunt the gray zapper the only
zapper that matters nice and my parents
like you get 45 minutes a day and do not
touch that thing on Sundays I'm like
sibility that's cool yeah yes you know
what I do right every kid did this back
in the day you tiptoe past their bedroom
at like 4:00 a.m. on a Saturday and you
hope your dad doesn't watch it something
too loud on that TV turn it on is your
game going then they finally come out
they're like all right time we started
I'm like so started with the 80s rocking
on so then from that point on you stayed
in the ecosystem in a tenant ecosystem
from what from that point on I did I did
yeah I mean I'll just hit a couple quick
favorite games like the teenage Ninja
Turtles arcade game that was one I had
to finally convince my mom like it's
just fighting there's not that much
matter that much humanity she didn't
read the instruction manual her Super
Mario Brothers because it was like
Bowser's black magic is what turned
bricks I'm like I gotta hide this thing
I book yeah so you know the Turtles the
arcade game was the first game as a kid
that I watched the Sun Rise because I've
been playing all night like that was the
first time I had ever gone done all
nighter I was at my buddy's house he
fell asleep I was like dude I just beat
it with one turtle be with the next
turtle beat it like so we had right but
then fast word a little bit and Super
Nintendo came out and my parents came
came through big mm-hmm and they were I
mean look no magic no fighting games
that was it my aunt gets me Street
Fighter 2 I'm eating rip that thing open
I'm like ain't getting returned my buddy
and I way to walk like this is no joke I
sound like such an old man we had a walk
to this rental store we're in the
country in this gas station at a rental
store we had to walk uphill both ways
I'm not
so many hills and Dan streetfighter I
played that thing I was like like this
has to be mine yes so when I Oh classic
force yeah yeah it was it was a it was
game over so yeah you just you know time
trials and stuff on Mario Kart with my
uncle Thanks just just hours and hours
of gaming on the supernal of that since
I gotta ask you this because there's a
lot of Sega kids on the panel so was it
more the fact that Nintendo because you
were introduced to it were you unaware
of it or was it the fact also with the
parent thing that maybe like that second
thing ain't gonna fly well just maybe
their games didn't really appeal to you
at that time well okay so like I had a
best friend growing up and and he had
the Nintendo also so like games like
when Super Mario Brothers 2 came out
like I can't like people get excited
about games now yeah but we have that
excitement like every other day there's
a new game we're excited for like back
then it was like you know you'd get the
the first issue of Nintendo Power so
Super Mario Brothers 2 and then that
games not coming out for a while but
that's the only game that's kind of
being talked about or the big game
anyway you know so like there's a
different level of hype that happened
back then I remember heat when the game
finally dropped there was a there was a
chip shortage so like I didn't get the
game till like a year after it came out
I saved my money and she had it in her
purse but it was never ever available
she finally came home with it um but he
was you know so him and I together he
had different games so the Intendant was
just kind of you know most of the kids
in the neighborhood had the Nintendo it
wasn't in except for the one rich kid
that had both salut salut the risk it so
I would go I would go stay at his place
quite often and play Sonic and shinobi
okay you know Mortal Kombat with the
blood that kind of stuff cuz that was my
jam no doubt and you know shout out to
general chaos some of the best Sega
games nobody's ever played it but I love
that game love it's like it's like
original Fire Emblem you know it's just
way back in the day so yeah so so I
wasn't like
I wasn't like a I didn't really hate the
Saiga is it just one PlayStation that's
what I hated wait what's happening how
did this happen
I like it to something now auuu welcome
here anytime
oh my god do we go do this place takes
but I gotta hear any story what's this
about alright so so the tender 64 comes
out mmm right
i buy Goldeneye and I buy Mario Kart
though I didn't here's a fun fact you
guys can all this is like one of the
shows i one of the questions I asked in
my shows is what is a game you haven't
played or haven't completed that we're
all gonna judge you for yeah you guys
can judge me I did not beat Mario 64
until last year Wow okay I've never beat
The Witcher I get judged by that all the
time the only one you ain't never played
The Witcher yeah I have it in my
collection it's never been in my xbox
things happen so wait wait get to this
part about the 64 you got these getting
what what's the PlayStation beef about
okay so I go to a I had never played it
I go to a buddy's house mm-hmm
first of all I'm like where's the
shooters wing and there's no there's no
shooters to be found that anybody that I
could find anyway remember this is
pre-internet it's like 96 right there
destructor like that was like chat rooms
that was about thanks like yeah you know
then movie the net was like the scariest
thing or careful you can order pizza
the the I go to his house we play Mortal
Kombat and there's these loading screens
and I'm like what is just like kicking
me right now I am like I can't I
I'm giving up game time watching this
thing how are you okay with this
I could put in killer instinct gold
right now and we played twice the amount
of matches like I can't shoot you in the
face
with any of the games you have oh like
Goldeneye oh right yes so I mean look
I'd beat to JRPGs my entire life to to
pokemon yellow and Xenoblade Chronicles
- Wow so that really it just wasn't
appealing to you like it just that he
said they're loading screen old so I get
the loading for so not even like the the
graphical Bliss of PlayStation what like
what was a monster
that didn't even attract you how to
games look I wanted to set crash on fire
you're his fanboy him let's get just get
right to it so this was the internet
endo of you wasn't feeling this young
aggressive Saudi and they had crashed
outside your building talking his talk
are you like this is trash you say
compared to barrio no I give Mario a
fire flower and let him take this guy
out that was that brash young Saudi that
was just all to see talking that talk
yeah yeah now I love I wish they put him
in smash with that megaphone to be like
so we skip PlayStation totally perfect
dark like I played 32 days played on
perfect dark you know they track your
time like nine hours
it said 32 days it's eventually erased
my little memory card that went in the
controller room Wow
and so that was a sad day I was near
perfect in that game wasn't I never hit
the number I was number two I could
never hit you had to kill X amount of
human players than the the sims didn't
count so hmm you know keep that in mind
if you're still going for that or
whatever it's on game pass you guys been
talking about it no no go for it go for
it
so tons of perfect dark tons of mario
kart mario golf mario tennis i just
gotta love all things all things mario
right so it's just it's just kind of
once once I once I had that taste back
in like 80
seven or whatever it was like it was
kind of game over for me you know the
whole of wasn't the stitch c69 with the
two-dollar switch at this guest is
definitely on to something
yeah the chat is this polarized at the
place there some people loving you it's
sort of like uh what's going on you know
you know Christopher Hart mr. Bahari
silent I haven't see they shout the boss
movies like Christopher probably passed
out with all the place it's kind of
funny but I just got asked because I
noticed you said keeping and I think
it's making sense to me you basically
said you know the Golden Eye was your
baby that shooter right so the fact that
at that time maybe places you didn't
really have that you weren't really into
junior RPGs is that maybe then what kind
of transmission jutsu like Xbox cuz I
know you have a big halo and you know
background far as what did you love
there okay so let's get to where it goes
here goes a quick cool story mm-hmm I
was newly married at 18 years old and
III think we were I think we were both
20 when the Gamecube came out right so
you know I think we I think we had I
think we may have our first kid or the
first kid was on the way okay and so not
a lot of cash wife is saving tips at the
coffee shop and Christmas morning I open
I'm not expecting anything lying to you
like based on a situation and there's a
GameCube and every other how every
family or friends house that we went to
was controllers Rogue Squadron Smash
Bros everything like we're talking like
the ultimate Christmas with with the
Gamecube so you know I'm waiting on
perfect dark to smash has got the
proximity mine is a little trophy right
like I'm like perfect darks gonna be the
thing what is this halo nonsense move
along like you're not even on the same
level as perfect dark and then microsoft
purchases rare yeah what's up good to me
bend the knee now you got
and I was a I was a youth pastor and
these kids are like you got to come play
Halo with us and I'm like with that
giant Big Mac of a controller Duke the
Duke was dumb big yeah so we I sit down
I look down and I'm just like this grass
looks amazing like I'm trying to play on
the Gamecube I'm trying to play like
these gold these these James Bond games
that are just garbage like agent under
fire night fire right there they're hot
garbage the first yeah it's an heir
apparent to Goldeneye it was like I'm
like okay finally something I can
something I can hang with you but no as
soon as I played halo I fell I fell in
love and like um the month that Xbox
Live came out I bought an Xbox it came
with Splinter Cell and mech assault yes
and and then two months later and moved
to a place that had broadband because it
was hard to have even fun and so got DSL
got Xbox Live DSL you know what I find
absolutely hilarious mmm is that he was
he was not willing to wait for
PlayStation load times but he's gonna
wait for that he saw the halo he said I
don't care how much I got a week the
grass looks great did you do any lame so
as he as a youth pastor I had all the
people I wanted to play with all the
time right so we're carrying see my
house was always full of CRTs and Xbox
and yeah okay so talk that lamp or to
talk let's go okay well so first I my
son was three and I'm not exaggerating
and I'm like he's just like I kind of
skipped all
like mario stuff with him i'm like just
play halo but go kill son no so for real
he has a spider in his room he runs out
he's like mom I need a grenade we see
someone in a crosswalk he's like I put
him up against three uh three of my
three my buddies who write like they
they they they are all like okay there
aren't Blood Gulch right and one of
them's a mulch my son pulls out of my
stool and takes him right out of the
tank
mm word puts his controller down and
leaves and my three are all out we all
four are all three of my buddies you
said three oh three years old
yo that first of all that pistol was a
beast let's just get don't we we we we
got again how proud of you as a father
at that point he beat you boys oh yeah
yeah for real it was the best now I mean
mind you these were not these were these
were not like your seasoned halo vets
these don't matter like grown-ass men
off the street yes yes okay so this will
happen for Halo 2 you guys know like at
Christmas time like where like your mom
would like take a construction paper and
make little rings and you'd rip one off
each day to get closer to Christmas when
they were a kid well that's what I did
for him with Halo 2 he had he had a big
halo 2 logo in the kitchen with these
gray rings coming off it he would rip a
ring off every day as we would get
closer and so count oh yeah and I had
gotten injured at work so darn it I was
stuck on my couch from like September or
from August until December and halo
helping to launch then oh wow so here it
is halo 2 I remember he comes running
out of his bedroom that morning it's
like let's go let's go pain right now
we go we go visit family later on it's
me and my boy against my uncle and his
boy and we're doing capture the flag on
Blood Gulch and I'm like are you you're
in the base you getting the flag he's
like yeah I'm like I think there's
someone in there he's like oh don't
worry it's just Ken that's my uncle he
wipes him out grabs the flag
my uncle's like looking at him like what
do you mean don't worry and she's kid is
hilarious bro yo halos who changed a
game bro like that dad to me I mean that
set off Xbox Live like that was do yeah
that might be yeah that might be one of
the most disrespectful things I've ever
heard don't worry it was so hilarious
his wingman they have bonded in video
game he's nobody
it was funny uncle Kim probably had the
drop on him and he's just turning around
I was like let me get this flag he told
me this one over that yes what's up man
Xbox love es sound going so you did a
good place right there oh yeah oh yeah
so crimson skies was another game that I
played a lot so and then my wife got
into it right one day I go to bed and I
can hear that she's talking with these
guys they're kind of flirting whether
right on Xbox Live they're like oh we'll
teach you the ropes I'm like I'll come
out and like give me the controller I
just wrecked
these cats just completely and they were
like hey maybe you could teach us
something she got so into that one point
we had to Sony Trinitron next to each
other truck with 2x boxes because we
were tired of doing split-screen and my
favorite thing to do in that game is you
get you get a single like large star and
you were the highest level right people
come in how do I get the star I'm like
oh as fast as you can hit B up a and
half the room with leaf because they
would all exit right
salute your FPS game is crazy
I got a askew book I got a fast-forward
a little bit I gotta ask you another
thing I see your history is that a lot
obviously a lot of the lords I know
podcast the name is so else he has some
destiny connotations for us I saw
destiny in that uh the Bioman is talking
about that okay so when destiny once
dropped I started the loot cast and then
I joined the dads of Destiny podcast
history today
yeah was turned into a misis yeah yeah
and so so quite a history with that
community mmm charity events they Bungie
invited me to the Destiny to reveal Wow
huh yeah so it was yeah quite a quite a
run with that game love love those guys
I'm actually getting a beer on tomorrow
with Cosmo the community man okay oh oh
that's right yeah it's right that's
gonna be your backyard cuz everyone's
right for the most yeah yeah
that's what's up man should do not even
really that you're jealous jealous
brother like that that's that's
definitely one of the games of the lords
- aw he's destinated but we can get and
so so here's the thing when when the
switch in destiny to kind of came out
they kind of overlapped I fell off with
destiny to you like you can just see
Activision's like yes and yes just kind
of just just just kind of ruin in that
game right and you could I mean you
could even kind of see it at like like
it kind of really on it was just like
this that they got that I mean we saw it
in one right they chopped up it cuts so
much stuff Marty got fired like it was
just it was kind of it was kind of a
mess especially when you when you look
at the at the roots of what Bungie is
and how great they are and how you know
it was just it was just a shame to see
like the the shaders costing money oh
yeah you know like yeah yeah yeah and it
just you you could just tell that it was
like they this wasn't Bungie yeah it was
there was influence behind this
you know I hate you that because the
community it was not at all probably
that's all-time low right after it was a
honeymoon period when it launched and
then it's at once people started to get
behind the scenes and see what was going
on they started to pick it apart and it
really committee really felt low and at
that time I remember shot debuggers we
actually started our destiny podcast
writing the last word right at the time
that's near that was at its lowest
because we were like yo these is what
they need to fix you need to get back to
roots they need to get out of this
Activision you know and give the
hardcore what they want instead of
making it this casual game that we
didn't really like and then it's a shame
that you left because you know what
forsaken came out that was definitely
like a pinnacle moment and it definitely
started to get things in the right track
but you don't know maybe September man
free to play about two weeks ago I fired
it up I needed a shooter and I was like
hey I hear I hear things are looking up
so so so I fired it up and you know jump
I have like I'm so low level and I don't
even know what the meta is for guns
anything like that and once a player and
but like you know so many good members
have met so many incredible people like
Mark turcotte from Guardian radio yes
one that told me like hey he was like
get your branding on point and just
start doing destiny it's gonna be huge
so that's what I did falou fun fact the
loot cast was originally called the last
word and my first guest was Cosmo stop
play this is crazy lay back cuz shout
out that's what I had it and then I want
a shout outs Carol 9 he had it and then
what we did is we went to everybody many
boxes or some real respectful thing
because obviously with a new cats in the
game so we like yo let you know you guys
had the name we wanted you know if you
guys are not using it and they were like
no go for it you guys are good
representatives or the community like we
give you you know they gave us the
blessing you know it's a to use the last
word so this is great and we had funny
you said that
mark Turcotte was one of our first get
your guess you know Sam from what
Guardian he said yeah good doom and
salute to those got crazy stories but
this is crazy the connections yeah stuff
that's go but yeah so I mean you might
know Guardian outposts yes you know that
is yes he was a co-host in the loot cast
for a while
we actually did the show live at
Guardian con two years ago oh wow that
was my first one that oh really you were
there yeah I was there so um so yeah
tons of fun with destiny then and bunchy
and you know all that stuff like just
yeah good good times and so I'm excited
to jump back in the hard thing is it's
like once the switch came out and I
started the Nintendo Power cast yeah
there were so many games oh and you know
the indie devs start sending you games
and I'm like okay I'll do a 15-minute
first look that's pretty much the best I
can give you because I'm a one-man show
mm-hmm I had one dad I uploaded 15
YouTube videos because like I played
that many different different games just
to try to get a little bit of info to my
community about it you know so so I
really didn't have time you know that I
started the Smash Bros cast when smash
was was a was announced I wanted to
learn to play competitively we went and
played Genesis six nice and I went 1 and
2 I won my first match absolutely so
basically what you say John is that
Nintendo has so many games you say
goddamn for nothing it's kind of the
case earlier this year for sure but
where what ok hmm I'm a workhorse Yeah
right I get I get up at 2:30 mm-hmm
I go to the gym mm-hmm I work 10 hour
day Lou say wake net break the one break
I get I walk a mile so I don't get off
of my feet until after 10 hours I'm
built I'm building custom cabinets ok
right I come home I stream for 3 hours
and then I try to do a little bit of
family time before I crash again and and
rinse and repeat and that's Monday
through Monday through Thursday Wow so
you said you build a custom cabinets
excuse me sir Mitro Oh like that yeah
yeah you see that statue next to the
backer here you might had to get some of
your hardware together the box that
brother I'm doing
room in the back so you said all that
sell that time investors so uh like I
don't even play games for fun right to
likes it like and so what happened for
me after III I've been going going hard
what school Nintendo started a Nintendo
Power podcast what's funny is I then got
the all of that search engine juice then
I was the only name of the algorithm
when they dropped oh wow
shot my downloads like through the roof
Wow right and grew my community
extensively dope because a lot of people
were like oh I thought this was the
official one and and then a handful were
like I think I like this better than the
official salutes algorithm just get
lucky that way yeah
and so I have an amazing community you
know like we're always gaming we're
always talking games it's just it's just
to your team was it hey zero and crawl
oh yeah yeah crawler right now and I
mean the original crew was like destined
ought was my original boy back on the
loot cast and know though you know and
he's he's back hanging out now you know
so it's just good times we're just I
mean
Mario Kart spend my jam on stream like
and you know it's good keep it going man
love love you love what you guys are
doing shout the Guru I'll know if he's
still in here but um yeah man like I
came across you guys there to it
obviously love to see and see you guys
interact together and um just like
seeing the energy and what you guys are
doing it's got a side track you one last
thing before I gotta ask some other big
question is Dom the the other talents of
Josh which is obviously you know do you
have the tremendous motivational book
you know the other castle and um then
another thing is your break is saying
like you gets busy like this people
don't realize like you out here you know
saying like you got a group what is it
all until today so today so tell me
about that old John you know what
obviously you know the the musical
prowess so like I mean a lot of the
building community and trying to try to
turn the side hustle into a full-time
dope gig right I'm gonna I'm gonna I
gotta come up with products to sell
right now so I have struggled back and
forth with depression and having it just
beat me down and so I wrote this book
another castle and the it's it's my
struggle with depression illustrated
with Super Mario Brothers and there's no
but now is you know I love how you put
it together sometimes in life like we
were climbing the mountain to get a
better view of the mountain Wrightson
and Mario we get to the end of the
castle were like yes I beat the game
it's especially when you're an Atari kid
mm-hmm when you get to the end of the
fourth the fourth level the fourth you
know world 1/4 you're thinking oh this
is this is it later this is the end of
the game and there's this little toad
that's like nothing right and sometimes
life you think you're gonna hit that
goal and it's like no sorry your
princess is in another castle and you
know it it it sucks but it's like hey
you know what what else do I get to
learn what else do I get to how am I
gonna level up here so that I can get to
that fact get to that next castle and so
you know if we can if we can keep our
perspective like that where it's like
instead of getting frustrated at the
lack of a goal just being excited that
the journey continues and you stand
you're still capable and you're still
able and then just you know put your
head down and work Baby Talk That Talk
buddy that's why I'm so now I saw the
joint and I know you got the little
motivational joint too and I upheaved
and I was like y'all I'm feeling this
cat because that's real and I'm saying
that's real a lot of times we we get
down on certain things it's not getting
a goal but you're not appreciating the
journey and like I said that joint might
not be for you right now but you just
keep pushing and you will get there when
you get to that blessing that you
eventually you know hopefully that you
do want so that right there and then the
second thing was on obviously you know
saying that the group you don't say so
is it like you and you mean how many
people in the group just me okay
so it's just you your means your
it's just it's just me yeah so low the
yeah at Kyle from Cupertino yes the
drummer that's in GarageBand right so
that's that's who's drumming for me
other than that I play all the other
instruments and just yeah like I mean
I've been playing music since I was 16
I've got to play over in Russia a couple
times going with with church groups
playing some heavy metal things like
that like I've kind of played the gambit
of like real mellow stuff right now
until today so it's like a couple months
ago we were on vacation for a week and I
was like you know what I'm gonna write
five songs in seven days I'm on vacation
I brought my iPad a couple microphones a
little iRig and it was again my like the
five stages of depression that I went
through and and so that's what the song
comes to my mind is how do you remember
the tight like here's the thing I've
been writing these songs so fast I
didn't remember how to play most video
hook though they're recorded but okay
here's the end of the song this is I
mean it's like it's like sappy love song
because like this because I'm jealous
have the not lot lights night as it
touches you beautiful face there's one
wait wait here it is
here's someone give you nobody's heard
this no we get exclusive this let's go
Legend of Zelda song oh right Cole it's
dangerous to go alone here's the chorus
let's go hang on get the words down here
okay
here it is here it is it all started
with a bearded man with a sword and
assassin take this it's dangerous to go
right now shout loud ease up the jaws
with the pipes let's get it best fear
bars no doubt we got some applauses in
there no doubt we got some meows in the
fix tape is gonna be dizzy setup is that
American Idol going on or the Lord no
this is late like that we make right now
you're saluted yo thank you for even
doing I'll put you on the spot I know I
did you cut a crazy I had to have some
fun but Oh real quick so we gotta ask
this question no we ask every guess I'd
be Lord and 64 chaps your top 5 games or
franchises of all time
okay well Super Mario Brothers it's
gonna be the top franchise Mario Kart I
can't put these in I've never put these
in order aqui no orders no or just yeah
right so come on but and when I say
Mario games I'm talking 3d to 2d like
everything right but Mario Kart then
also gets its own franchise because it's
its kart racer that I Super Metroid was
the first time I had like an emotional
experience with the game like spoilers
but when that Metroid came down to save
you I was like
I'm like I'm like 12 years old like dad
my Metroid just saved me very very old
burial court Metroid that's three halo
yes halos halos gotta be in there
[Music]
there's so many games legend himself no
of course of course got those LV bit
salute no doubt strong v respect out
here should made this history judge but
I love a love what I'm hearing so we go
get into the show we got a lot stuff to
talk about so what we're an hour in I
know that was the intro I don't know we
listened we told you can you stay cuz
this is how we rock remember I was like
yo we long form brother yeah you know
but not it's all good man we love this
kind of stuff tremendous history man so
what yeah last week's poll results are
in and the people have spoken to the
question with both the latest gameplay
and information reveals of death
training at TGS and Gamescom how has
this affected your excitement of its
release on November 8 for ps4 the winner
of a highly contested three-way ILP poll
at 39% is that I'm more excited for
death stranding kijima is attempting
something cool a unique group second
place very close 30 to visit was the
death stranding is a FedEx baby walking
simulator group and in last place with a
razor close 30% was that I don't care
Konami by the author subject to all the
lords who participated in the poll I
gotta get Lord addict on this he's been
the biggest supporter of death training
so I need input
Lord active people must have
straitjackets accorded me you because
they all voted that Cagiva is onto
something they're feeling destron
I don't have straitjackets they will
soon trust so what do you fit up the
people band they they they not agree
with the laws they say they think this
is this is unique and cold look man
sometimes even smart people are wrong
dizzy just cuz you asked for it
you knew all those dudes is fraud news
oh but dizzy I don't know if you watch
last week I'm gonna be buying that baby
walking simulator yeah you wait I
already know you in oh just a dirty
water baby
everybody in the poll we already know
what's going on we got to do pull at the
end of show but we gonna get into these
topics man can I use my pokeball the
level up that baby standing slander oh
yeah we gotta get it to a met Lord
addict I don't know if you picked it up
but we'll start with you and Josh um
zelda's awakening man it is out here in
the streets the reviews are going down
looks like currently sitting at an 88
Metacritic right now
so what's too low yeah that's too low
that's that's too low okay first of all
let me tell you something three their
breakdown that game it didn't start it
up cuz it was at the top down games but
y'all wasn't like aware of those games
but this point essentially made that
genre what it is that game is a pillar
so a remake and it looks gorgeous the
scores is too low now that game should
have a 98 Metacritic it should be higher
than that and I didn't even play yet but
I'm buying it and I'm definitely gonna
buy it but from what I saw from what I
know of the game I don't care what
anybody say that game is supposed to be
in 98 and anybody out there fraud an
anomaly joke about the switch I know I
may tell you all this stuff about the
switch that's the stuff that I want
the switch so when they do something
that I want and it looks amazing
it looks amazing I don't give what
anybody say my level of frustration with
it is that this Metacritic stuff is
formulated in people's opinion about a
game that they either didn't play or
never experienced let's say time he goes
to the store and he's milling Metacritic
I think this is a a tool I don't want to
get that because this game no this is
the game that you definitely need to get
because it's gonna be a pillar inside
your gaming memories that's that's a
great game I'm gonna pick it up today no
doubt so let's get it was gay I think so
song did you pick it up yeah I
definitely picked it up okay doesn't
have want me go at it no no I was gonna
Gus gonna I just want to know if you
picked that first and I was gonna ask or
some of us I'm gonna assume Josh
probably has the most experience out of
all of us right now as far as playing so
so Josh let's get to you man um just now
that you've you know bidding grace you
know initiate it with it you had the
weekend you know you kind of said you're
gonna dedicate to streaming it and stuff
like that what's your overall feeling
and the pressures of the game so far so
I love it like period like that's it I
love it it's exactly what I was wanting
for this weekend of like like kind of
just me time right and like as much as I
loved breath of the wild mmm and and
that open world stuff like this like
having just that classic Zelda formula
back this thing is like I don't use
words like cute or adorable very often
but this game is the norm right like
mm-hmm
it's like you're it's like you're
playing in your toy box with these with
these characters I mean look look at
this exactly
look at this this guy here King you oh
I'm down with you yeah he's a nipple
King that's what some you see them over
there right they all over there another
season seed fun fact behind me in that
closet is every amiibo still in its box
oh that's two best friends It's A Wrap
It's A Wrap
[Laughter]
so a quick question quickly I gotta slow
you ordered me what does it give you
specifically because King is all about
his advantages premium advantages for me
but doesn't give you a premium advantage
this gives you hang on it says it's
somewhere on here I think it gives you
shadow link in the dungeon I'm running
to the store so we get an exclusive
behind a wall content King he loves this
Amazon right now you can use the amiibo
to share and trade custom dungeons with
your friends it takes five amiibo to
unlock all of the the other features of
the dungeons there's stuff that's
unlocked behind any button I don't know
that it matters it does I'm literally
ordering it right now
right there you Link's Awakening yeah
mm-hmm
this is hilarious really I got it all
morning just awoke in net premium
Explorer he loves this I got it I'm
honest I got it right now I was 26 books
is Bangkok
no it's 15 at Best Buy oh if I can find
it see that's the whole thing I got I
got it
I got a rabbit group of dudes they're
going in and I see them as I'm walking
and they're looking at me like got you
today and we tried to get the lowest
price and those dudes snatch him up and
he leave so we gotta wait for the
restock so sometimes I hit the dudes a
little bit of bread but I didn't hit him
with the bread because I didn't know
that they had that but I paid to 2608
they come tomorrow
yeah sure there's a problem but good to
you Josh continue yeah so I mean this
I'm just having a great time with it
it's the you know it's I've only played
I'm already further in this version than
I wasn't any of the handhelds I used to
take like a gameboy on vacation with me
and like the the DX version or whatever
and and just try to you know play
through and whatnot and the you know I
see some people whining about the
framerate and I'm just like you I just I
don't like I come from the NES days
where
games would slow to like two frames
right like this is not I don't know it's
not it's not is it overblown to you is
it like people is it not a big deal or
is it noticeable but not just
distracting enough to ruin the overall
experience I've noticed it for like the
less than 2 to 3 seconds it happens and
then it doesn't it affects it's 0 gosh
let me ask you a question right okay so
is the transition only when is the
screen going from cookie because
remember the old game was when you cross
from screen to screen that's when the
transition was so when I was watching
digital foundry they were saying like
when you went from screen to screen that
that's when the slowdown would occur
slightly that's why I saw it yeah and
it's it to me it feels like it's almost
like in certain areas like where you get
close to the mystery forest where it
actually changes the colour of the way
the level looks it's it's almost like
instead of just having like a handful of
little squares like that giant like
whatever whatever all those squares that
make up the mystery forest it's been a
transition from that to that that's when
you're gonna see a little bit of this
hiccup right oh you don't you don't
notice it every time you would be moving
to a new square like in the poker game
it's only like to the newer the newer
areas and it's so minimal like I just I
don't know I've come to the conclusion
that a lot of gamers wake up trying to
figure out what they could be pissed off
about today right like true you know if
it wasn't this framerate thing it would
be something else the expression on his
face or it's just I I don't I don't get
it how much I feel you know I'm glad you
said that man and I got actually cut
before I pass softly I don't saw a plate
I just want to get people play for is
you mentioned a critical thing and shot
again Nintendo girl for had we we had
this discussion to reference to my love
foot for breath in a while right and for
me personally speaking like I love that
3d transition but I'm hearing from the
hardcore Zelda community like they like
yo 2d so that is where sad baby like
this
so like your experience you know I mean
obviously one is a remake and one is a
new game so we ain't gonna really do
apples to apples but my question is like
2d Zelda dough is more your speed
like what's more you Josh it I was
making sure you're talking to me - yeah
ask you today don't you name on it so I
think there's room for both I don't want
to be I love that classic Zelda
experience because that's what I grew up
with right right but for the the
generation that breath of the wildest
may be their first Zelda game they may
look at this and be like what you know
and they may also be like this is really
difficult like you know try and and and
and maybe not understanding that like
know this was what an open-world game
was back and I mean the original Zelda
is an open-world game mm-hmm right but
and so it's it's I think there's a place
for both of them and I think Nintendo
needs to continue I think we need
Oracle's and Ages needs to like the
seasons and Ages whatever there's they
need to come out next year like like
let's let's keep this going let's let's
get like maybe Link to the Past maybe
and new let me look the link between
worlds Oh new like yeah and but the
thing is what we saw was kind of a we
saw this a little bit of a dumbing down
of the of the the the just the way it
was right like you can rent the items
instead of having to get through the
dungeons to get an item like now let's
not make it too easy let's keep it back
mmm like they get in it and what they
did on this one I love they gave normal
mode and they gave hero mode mmm right
so that if you want to not have enemy
enemies drop hearts and you've got to
play this a little like you got to play
safe and smart and like I'm I'm down
with that
no give us give us those options but I
breath the wild - I can't wait for it if
there's dungeons it's gonna be the
perfect Zelda game in my mind like and
that's what addicts like the contention
with the dungeon part you know yeah like
and just some unique bosses because of
those Ganon lights or whatever they were
just kind of boring there was nothing
there was there was no be honest with
you like
it was the fact that I was playing Zelda
after so long but if you want to like go
zelda 2 zeldas breadth of the while it's
probably one of the words though that's
how I get what he's saying it's not it
doesn't it's not a pillar Zelda you know
what it is it changes the formula up
from what you gotta cottages up too much
why we not gonna disrespect why I got
back without a game is just it's not one
of the best Zelda game you have to break
it down in this way right because
everybody likes different things yeah
and I mean you you think I'm trolling
you when I tell you like I like Skyward
Sword you really think like I'm trolling
you but I'm not but I really like it and
everybody something wrong with you yeah
but see you would you would you would
look at me and be like and I understand
and I get it but when I went to the
store and I purchased it and I was able
to swing a sword with my Wii Remote
that's all I ever wanted to do in Zelda
so when they gave me that option to do
that in with my Wii Remote that put that
Zelda game a way above to me just to me
so when I was able to do like the bow
and stuff like that listen um some
people like he said some people may see
in breath go wild and say that is the
most amazing zelda and made go back to
this awakening and say hmm I'm not real
too keen on that and maybe they might
get a Nintendo mini and played the old
Zelda and be like definitely don't want
that um but it's like this each is own
but the fact that they did switch it up
so much and they did put this self out
there I don't I wouldn't say that it's a
is one of the words elders I think is
one of the best elders but it's for each
is own like maybe I mean as much as
pissing me off right now I understand he
said to me you know there but um again I
gotta jump in you got understand for me
the reason why I'm such a defender of
breath little wild is like King knows
like Nintendo was in the bushes for me
like completely like for me
I stopped with Nintendo probably after
Josh's namesake the 64 like the 64 and
I'm [ __ ] we knew his chance to talk as
well to you about 64 but um you know the
64 for me was like the last joint for me
that the four player you had name and
law and then you had the arm to me the
best wrestling games ever we go his
tummy's not even dispute you know if you
know they that no Mercy's all that was
the goal to be so that was my last think
you was okay it wasn't wack to me but
just okay you know saying but since then
I would just like naughty doing the same
old stuff you know the first part is
strong but they're never gonna have
third party they're never gonna do
mature stuff and when I saw the switch
commercial and I saw gel de I'm like
this is Nintendo evolving now this is
this is what I wanted to see and I was
tired of they don't get me wrong like
Link's Awakening stuff that's classic
that's vintage I get it but breath
little Wow showed me yo they grew up now
now they in this generates a press a
little bit wouldn't appeal to him it's
Twilight Princess is like one of the
darkest odors itself on the wheel like
it was me I was not we I was not there I
mean the art direction that he would not
be a pill it would not appeal to him the
art direction yes it was out your air
Twilight this is one of the most like
realistic art directions for me again
the reason why I'm such a fan play for
it is because I wanted them to grow up I
wanted them to do what this current
generation is doing and I don't know if
it's the new leadership or whatever it
was switch and this Zelda represented
that that's why I'm I go so hard for
switch now because I'm like this is what
I need to see and I love that like you
said Josh both can co-exist right you
can have this belt for me the guys who
went away from Nintendo and this brought
us back but then they got awakening for
you guys like yo this is the classics
we like that that you know I'm saying
and I love it so I just wanted to get
that off
ladle gonna call for addicts Lander but
we got to get it back to solve solve you
got copped it where you're at with it
man well the thing is I come at it from
a different perspective kind of as a
newbie to this particular game because I
don't have nostalgia for the game boy
like you as well cog and probably King
to a certain extent by the time the game
boy was really big we were a little
older and it worked it fit more like
[ __ ] about tsukai BOTS who is big into
and probably addict as well like they
played more more than we did at that
point you know I looked at the game boy
is like the kid system I'm saying I
wanna I want a portable I want that game
gear failed console portable that went
up against the game I've ever failed
with yeah so we were looking at like
we're looking at game here link store
like the turbo Express or I was the
Nomad out at that point or not yet
yeah no man we were like nah we don't we
don't play that so I honestly I never
played the original I know kabocha day
but I did it so coming to it now I like
Josh said before like the game is it's
adorable
and it's it's like it's such a joy to
play like it's such it's so whimsical
but then it has all the core pillars of
what a Zelda game is so it's a type of
thing like for me now I don't have time
to sit down with a game that requires me
to a super amount of time to get
anything out of it and it's game you can
play for a little while just have fun
with it and you could you know be in a
the only thing is like a and a dungeon
they're gonna take you back out to the
start of the dungeon but beyond that if
you're in the overworld wherever you
stop you can continue from and yeah you
have this suspend also they I guess
which has the best suspended individual
in a business yeah I love this because
there's plenty of times on that xbox I
suspend and come back and it'll restart
the game is not where it's at like it's
not not always is not all the time it's
not every game
who said that like they're suspend is
literally a pause button like it's it's
all that is how receiving pause like is
instant but could do yeah so um but I
I'm loving it
you know that always cool and the thing
I do have affinity for old-school Zelda
because I did play a link to the past
and so I just never got clay to get
anything on Gameboy sort of play this
now let's see we've done with it yeah I
was a little initially off-put by the by
by by the transition frames I was like
wow this is it's a little strange
because Nintendo stuff is usually super
polished but whatever the case may be it
is minimal it's not a big deal the game
is so much fun it's so pretty
mm-hmm and it's perfect I'll be honest
this this selling light with it um and
some in some instances it is a perfect
game to get a younger gamer you know get
the mists which like get them with this
game it's Zelda but it's accessible
enough that it's it's not super
confusing so actually the I picked up
two lights and the stand still you
picked up you know what is this fitting
that they launched the game with the new
stand still and the stand the fact that
you know they launched a whip that
because when you had the Gameboy is when
I had two Gameboy one that was one of
the games this was a couple of games on
Gameboy that was really like little
powerhouse games for the Game Boy even
though it didn't have you know was the
monochrome thing and it didn't have the
color those games certain games stood
out and that was one of the games that
stood out and the fact that you know
they launched in the stand still with
this game this game definitely is one of
the games it was a bright I when I saw
it and I thought wow they are really
going for all the gustl you got two
Zelda's in this generation with this it
this is really an amazing time for
Nintendo to be honest with you because
we thought it was flat dead and they
actually did a huge comeback this is
beautiful yeah absolutely I can complete
greet you King I think that's why I was
very happy for them just like you know
cuz again in my mind a was dead
I really wasn't part of the even though
the wheat was successful I wasn't really
in on it and the way you I just didn't
like it also to see the success they
have him with the switch is just
tremendous I want to ask attic you know
obviously you're a huge fan you know
what's your feeling I don't even get to
pick it up you lose from what you've
seen like where you at with Link's
Awakening I'll pick it up on however I
get around so I mean I want to play but
at the same time like I could wait yeah
but you've seen the like um the game
paths you older big yeah so you uh for
what you've seen no wait what have you
like what you seen I mean I don't not
like what I seen like I can't say like
I'm hyped or anything for but it's a
Zelda game and I'm about Zelda game so
pretty much I mean the lowest kind of
knocked it out the park being literally
in agreement with all you guys I think
josh is is literally saying it's just
adorable love letter remake you know
saying it's just killing it right now
I'm hearing the sales are really
tremendous man so salute it's a Nintendo
look like they got another one you know
I'm saying but that's all I got listen
where else has anything for we move on
Lord King we gonna have to PlayStation
fives is this monkey see monkey dude
[Laughter]
check it out wasn't me not too long ago
an aha and a Conde a Lockhart with oh
that's a stupid idea
I can't believe that I did
why would Microsoft split the
demographic in such a way I can't
believe Microsoft will even think this
way this is an exact thinking that has
got them second place as we know and we
must try to grab sure dick can you see
the king is walking around with no
clothes has lost his mind and he thinks
that Sony as we know is the king right
now right guys our King has just told
you day in date we will drop to we will
drop to PlayStation 5 we will drop a bro
and we would drop a regular and this is
coming from a sauce Oh first let me tell
you um brand out though has been hitting
it out the park oh yeah a little rain
shout out to Rand okay so when Rand put
it up I looked at it sent a link over
the car I'm like this this is fantastic
the top is up I want it is mine and the
only reason why I bring this topic to
you guys is because the level of
hypocrisy that I see coming from the
media coming from the little community
coming from super fanboys and that were
going Microsoft under the bus if they do
this this is this is outright lunacy
what is the same energy oh you're still
in the poll question right now this is
crazy you literally verbatim video a
pocket with a with the poll question
store has been telling everybody Jimmy
so basically you know obviously we heard
the news come out and um let's frame it
so basically what's happening is the
rumors or shephelah shoutout to mods
gaming Lord gave me dotnet one of the
first to put it up there you know say
but the sauce seems credible you know
and the sauce basically said that on you
know he's here did they looking to have
the place
in five and a pro version hopefully
available you know for launch when it
when it drops so let's bring it to the
roundtable let's get Josh in on this
Lord Josh like you know with this news
you know one how do you feel about it do
you think this is a mistake do you think
you know you're cool with it like where
you at with this potential rumor as long
as it can run game pass I don't care
like they're very good about the SKUs
themselves I mean look I video games are
still business whether people like that
they love people
I've had people like block me on Twitter
for telling them like you remember this
is a business right this is art I'm like
it's still a business
somebody's gotta fun that art alright
like yes it's the way it is if they can
come out with skews that allow people
that can't afford the pro mm-hm to get
into the they're gonna sell more they're
gonna they're gonna sell more period if
they have one come out at $2.99 and one
come out it's at $4.99 mm-hmm it's it's
it's not gonna sell it's all gonna sell
and you're not gonna have people that
are like oh why do we get I mean look
PlayStation 4 and Xbox one came out two
years late because of the economy being
bad so we got these systems that were
already dated the moment they came out
yeah right that with the economy the way
it is we're more than likely going to
get systems that are at the top of the
range so even even the lower end model
is still gonna be screaming and the high
end while I was looking at an 8k TV
yesterday and Best Buy
right so there's a good chance it's
probably gonna be power and that kind of
stuff that's gonna be a that that TV was
five grand mmm okay so you're not gonna
be talking about a huge demographic of
people that are gonna be gaming and a
key I don't even know if it's gonna do a
cape right I'm just we just saying
it all kind of goes that way right we've
seen them we've seen how this works so
look options for the consumer I always
look at them as a good thing because as
long as they're not pulling like the
Nintendo thing where it's like oh this
only runs on the new DS you know that
kind of stuff is not that's not a good
thing to do right but I mean for the for
the average consumer that's still
rocking a 1080p TV mm-hmm as long as the
games still run at 1080p 60 right
why get that they may not need the per
let let me let me let me give you the
counterpoint Josh I just wanna ask you
just what about for those who say to
skews like King was alluding to like
when you know that to skews confuse the
market like why split up the demographic
like do you feel just is it because
PlayStation is like just so popular
they've been you know has such a great
generation it won't matter you know I'm
saying or do you like do you not agree
with that thought process they've sold
what probably close to a hundred million
ps4s at this point we haven't I don't
know the last time we saw numbers but I
mean it's like and there's three of them
on the market right now right or is it
just to use just the slim in the pro now
I don't know I have it that's all I can
go shopping for them right business 3
slim in the pro is the regular still
sold that's all I wasn't sure I ran out
of them already running out of the
allotment of them but whenever they're
gone I think they're dead
let me got you so I mean right now
consumers are already used to 3 on the
shelves mm-hmm yeah right
so yeah so you saying basically what you
say did they not confuse them there you
go go that they could base it because
who was smart enough to put that
together
III would say so I mean it's it's it's
what
Xbox is the same effort now Nintendo's
the same way the DS is the same way oh
good point right like it's just that
we've we've the the the I mean the
average consumer that's going out like
grandma going to buy for her for her
grandson or granddaughter and sure maybe
they're gonna be a little bit like well
which one should I get
mmm but that's I think the majority of
the people buying it they're gonna know
what's up
friend of Lord addict man PlayStation 5
Pro and bass at launch way at with this
man I mean as long as I feel like it's
it's better as long as it's a choice
from the start and not in the middle
mm-hmm because at least from the start
the the devs can at least like take in
mind of that product from the start
uh you got a slash out there sir I
didn't see I got two dollar super chef
from JD gamers PlayStation ponies
nothing bad to say about PS 5 pro I
think you're onto something
it's cool if you want that you can get
that I'm just kind of curious like how
everyone else is gonna receive that
information but you know method botamo
moto we got to see exactly how that
works
um if they're originally take advantage
of the pro on launch right cuz I don't
know exactly how that's gonna because
this this mid generation this this
higher SKU it's it's a new thing it's
it's not it's not something that's been
around for a while and I think the
industry itself is still trying to
figure out how to do this um King I have
a super Chester another coach King this
is stitch
with the flawless super jet King one
PlayStation is gonna be the regular pro
is going to have the car back wake up at
the same as we do it in the needs of
can't play back a bad but the pro could
solve it kid yeah I gotta bend to me
what if that is a dig what if like the
program does daddy
no no no no I will not want these from
him if they put out to sea and one can't
play back a pack and the pro could
that's that's dead wrong a consumer
that's not consumer friendly I was in on
that and we just be there with that
together all together that don't make no
sense but a card reader do come up but
do you adequately say I've got the
PlayStation 5 Pro addict is the
butcher's already we lose them oh ok so
let's get this solved that get your game
solve what do you think man I mean
honestly I had to laugh when I saw this
just because it's like really it's not
something that I think they need to do
when when they were going to talk about
Xbox going that route I agreed with it
because I said you know what it's a
protection for them if they come out
with an inferior console-based console
to the PlayStation 5 because the
internet will not let them live that
down again just one right so I said you
know what
give me that $600 column whatever it
just make sure it's more powerful and by
a considerable amount
but once they decided that wasn't the
route to go I thought about it and it
does make sense because what you do is
that you immediately devalue the lesser
product at launch immediately and you're
devaluing the product that you're
expecting to sell more records all right
so it's it's it's a catch-22 it's very
it's an oh oh
salud that's my homie to dodge night it
was just a suit pound dollar for every
currency I gotta say that because some
of the courtesies I don't know we dodged
I've every time I put up my Jim tweets
he sends back pictures of food and bad
stuff the heat that's my guy right there
so look at it dodge thank you but
hopefully we see you at e3 brother but
continue so yeah so sad oxidized night
with the Lord's Day young Lords day Lord
day so honestly I
I thought it was something that
Microsoft sort of needed to do to
protect themselves from from that sort
of scrutiny it's not something that Sony
needs to do and it's just going to
create a bit this is true it's gonna
create a level of confusion Oh check
that can affect them adversely which
does not agree with this no no no
honestly after thinking about it and
seeing you know again I was down for
four xbox because of where they stood
and what they needed to do to make sure
mm-hmm that they were on top power wise
especially you know when the narrative
and and the talk out of them wasn't it's
gonna be the most powerful anymore it
was I guess revolve or like but those
the words change so whatever you need to
do to make sure you keep on top of that
narrative mmm-hmm for a station doesn't
need to say on top of that narrative
they can they can have the weaker
console and it's you know I don't think
it's gonna affect them nearly as much so
I don't think this would work for them
honestly I think it's gonna serve to
confuse people and the same thing that
would have happened to xbox I think what
would happen to them is that you're
going to devalue a console that that
ideally is gonna sell more hold on I
gotta back yourself I gonna let you go
just yet but question is Dave what about
people who just say you gotta keep the
same energy like you were cool with it
when all whether they had a Condon
Lockhart but that if somebody doing it
you leave nice and specifically because
of where where Xbox is and what things
you pretty much say so the marking later
they don't need to do anything do it
okay but their risk confusion by doing
is on your neck sighs this is fraud talk
openly telling you that Xbox needs the
security blanket so basically you try to
give heart property like yo yadda
leading I don't need to do this you're
literally doing what I said you would do
is snatching victory from snatching
defeat from the jaws of victory right
you're creating scenarios for yourself
that can get you into trouble for no
reason then you on the ROI claim a piano
before the fight and
as the market leader in a dominant
position they don't need to do this is
what you say don't need to do this and
Microsoft in my opinion if they had gone
that route I would have understand
standard why they saw you out - JD
gaming with the five dollar super tech
Microsoft should release two consoles as
they initially wanted to and the lower
power system will be fine with no
devaluation but it's based on the
messaging let me alright cuz I pick you
on the sunscreen JD gamer and let me
explain why I think you're onto
something and this is exactly what I
think
sovereigns point is first they don't
need to do it because they're superior
right and this point I'm sole is
perceived to be right okay now then
opposite superior power-wise is superior
in numbers paper champions let me mark
why they're paper champion Josh you got
a great ready for the slam to do it's
not slam there's just facts okay art
he's about the master but we both pull
up in Benzes see I want you to
understand this part you scold a hundred
million but we both pull up in Benzes
how is that possible it's possible
because the level of services and stuff
that Microsoft is selling is actually
making the same amount of money you're
making what selling hardware now this is
where you're going to mess up at if you
do this this is sovereigns thinking
you're the boss you don't need to do
that you don't need to devalue one
system just to push it out the door but
if you do so what happens if Microsoft
goes back and says you know what let's
revisit the two cars right and this
makes sense for Microsoft because they
ecosystem actually is equal friendly for
that they're trying to get game pass on
everything right so the games actually
run the same all over the place but
PlayStation wants to be superior more
powerful you want to come out with one
system first make them buy that make it
be tapper
then come out with what a standstill
later internal written come out with a
pro they came out with a weaker system
and it's selling like hotcakes mm-hmm so
I think this is that the big mistake
that's gonna happen and I know sovereign
is seeing them actually winning they're
winning the race and they decide to tie
a sneaker let's get a job get Oh Josh
there is one major difference though and
what and what you're saying and the
switch light is completely handheld
that's what other things good it serves
its purpose in in being a handheld
system right where to come out later
with a for Sony to come out later with a
weaker system seems like I don't know
maybe because the Vita was so great
diametrically opposed to the standstill
mm-hmm all right yeah because all right
the the originals is portable right you
call so docket but they eliminated the
whole suite nope yeah you could take the
little thing switch you was able to
switch it back and forth right that the
whole word switch means to change right
to switch I got you though I got you I
know what like the moment the moment you
see a switch fall out of somebody's
pocket and the joy Khan's grenade off of
that exactly and nobody don't want these
kids with them you yourself was was was
hesitate about getting them no the big
one your listen I'm a hypocrite
all right listen let's let's put this up
let's put this up right now I'm waiting
right now for Black Friday to go get my
son his stand still take those things
apart and lose them with you understand
the the thought process of life
videos on on that light it's like a cop
man Nintendo can do to to skews but Sony
can't this is what we have of what his
rebuttal what Josh's rebuttal yes what
way I'm sorry what was the question
worse on Nintendo because they have a
product that does everything and then
they have a product that's only handheld
so like it's kind of weird though okay
you have a switch that connects to your
TV and then you have a switch light that
doesn't really it like the name doesn't
show it's like now it doesn't like say
switch TV less or anything like that
so like what are you talking to someone
they're like you have to switch I'm
playing on like so I'm playing it on my
TV and you got a gay stop because I
switch light they don't know the
difference they pick up the light and
you know obviously the person again so I
was probably gonna tell the difference
but let's say that person's brand-new
don't know anything they take that they
take that home it's like well how is the
hook up to the TV yeah you don't even do
it is it on the box anywhere I don't I
mean Dave they're going by that lower
arm icon and a shout-out to uh Richie
Ledbetter from digital founder you broke
it down like the way it's set up you
there is no way possible he can dock
like he can't fit the dock from what I
understand I'm and then there's the the
HDMI thing is it's not even there for
anything cuz you have it right Josh no I
did not oh wow son probably has a real
switch try to go come for the man no we
got I mean we have three switches in the
house right yeah I thought about going
and getting a light just so I could talk
about it on the show and things like
that my youngest is 11 so I'm not
worried about your dropping stuff and
they're huge Animal Crossing fans so and
so to give you your answer on why they
would do this I want you guys to look
carefully at all of the games that have
come out this year the main heavy
hitters for Nintendo
we're all 3ds games yes the last time
they released there are like I'm trying
to pull the numbers up here but like
I mean the 3ds two Bs in December of
2017 I think it's sold three quarters of
a million units right like the handheld
market is very very properly and if they
cannot split their devs between the
handheld market and have a system I mean
look the the 3ds came in at 299
I'm sorry 199 149 and $79 mm-hmm it
would not surprise me if eventually we
see a switch Pro come in at 299 mark
come say girl you got a sake switch Pro
coming in hot and a 200 that's my slogan
that's my slowly the switch light coming
in it at hot rapid and down to like what
whatever you guys like to the original
switch coming in at like $1.99 and then
the light even drop it further hmm right
so that so that they can pick up these
they look they just want investors to be
like yeah we see sales here's one money
there's no money is alone oh let me like
and and the other reason is is money you
know how much profit they're probably
making on the light compared to the
original switch oh absolutely because
you're talking about heart took
everything out but you're talking about
hardware that's that's three years old
now that was already dated technology
when it came out that's why the price is
so low anyway higher profit margins on
these lights yeah absolutely so that
like I mean and they he wants you to
throw alongside when it lakes awakening
I mean there's no c'mon yeah oh do you
think that now since this light is a
thing that in the next like year maybe
year and a half Nintendo's gonna
announce that they discontinued in the
3ds they I think has discontinued
already but in you don't they put it out
yet but I think didn't I just saw
something about it I think that
definitely I was already
mmm the way I would say you know
indirectly more so I would say anything
shows that you know the the 30s is in
the bushes is just the fact that Pokemon
is on the switch like yeah that's always
been there like golden goose when it
comes to their hand now it's like it
doesn't matter we can literally just put
a Pokemon this entire markets gonna sell
oh the crazy thing is that 3d s is still
gonna sell gangbusters in his Christmas
I just saw an advertisement for like
four to Nintendo as games with the
purchase they try to clear out let me
jump in because I know we going only to
be kind of diverted from interest rates
but all back you back to the PlayStation
joint like completely switch or the
PlayStation talvik it's interesting bro
is really until I was I was very
surprised when I saw this news I I
didn't think I kind of greedy like I
didn't think Sony would even entertain
that like to be honest you know I'm
saying but um I mean they're in the
driver's seat where I I still think
whatever they do is gonna be fine you
know I'm saying for the most part I
think that the question I have is is
there gonna be that much of a disparity
powerline yeah you know what I think you
know other thing happen mm-hmm I think
you know people could say what they want
I think they were seeing all that hype
and stuff games like Red Dead God you
know cuz when I game runs better on the
X like everyone is saying it does
especially they they had people at IGN
saying they're gonna go out and buy an X
just to play Red Dead on the mm but I'm
lying but after so I think you know
Saudis like you know we we still ahead
we still kill in the competition but we
want this not to happen as much as well
as it did in there but yeah I mean we
definitely saw the success of the X you
know you know what digital front you got
ahold of it and we saw the comparisons
it definitely helped Microsoft you know
in the generation with the Refresh you
know the question I got like I said is
how big the disparity isn't gonna be
between the base level P at five and a
pearl if this is to be true and then on
also
yeah yeah I think it's like just maybe
$100 difference what could it possibly
be right now well that's one thing I'm
thinking the thing I'm going with solve
I think maybe if there is a disparity
like the maybe the pro will have more
memory and like a bigger SSD you know
I'm saying cuz I would it they well you
have to assume the CPUs got to be the
same right because you got to have some
level of compatibility so that's where
I'm going with what you think so as far
as yeah I think I think if this is real
yeah well I would assume a faster CP
along the I'm going to need it's bugging
out again connection it's not really as
much like a connection is oh yeah I'd
better if you the body cream don't know
try charging it jump job I'll jump in
you robot it the robot in a little bit I
put a bow tie on it that's crazy
then it comes to this particular thing
you know I'm just curious what the base
Playstations gonna come out as like is
it is the base PlayStation gonna be five
in the premium gonna be like six to
seven like yeah I think like cuz at the
end of the day like is the base
PlayStation gonna be four cuz I don't
think it is yeah the keys gonna be proud
maybe you know they try to make it a
little bit cheap when it comes to the
next gen and worried the premium is only
the SSD and the regular is this a it's
just a mechanical drive like I don't I
don't know what they're gonna go with
that cuz I don't see especially there's
a difference between the pro and the
PlayStation and the X and the regular
Xbox they came out like three to four
years after the base model came out
right so it was easier to have
improvements because technology improved
technology got smaller is easier to make
stuff technology got cheaper right but
now since this you literally come out
the same time it's got to be skewed sir
oh no doubt a dick you wanna get tested
which at yeah just let me bring up the
chat again keep talkin
I literally just closed it out on high
school we got solved back to solving
back the building yes I'm back in the
building
oh you son clean clean clean clean you
finished finishing points off don't we
get adequate super jet what
I don't remember my damn point you're
talking about the council that's
literally all we got from you before you
bought of that power disparity Oh Howard
its back yeah I mean if there is a pro
version yet I think CPU will be faster I
think a bigger SSD makes sense good and
you know you might have a few extra
flaps you know I for some reason I feel
like they might take that route and the
premium product only has the SSD not
even you know because they touted that
big howdy or Bernie Ben but but they
talented that but then but that was
before we knew there was two skews put
it this way this is still rumor though
it would be a cataclysmic mistake for
one to have an SSD and the other two
that beat from the judge that would be
altered me tell you is that was the way
they would save money because right now
like I just don't like if you have the
base place they should come out being
500 because they have an SSD and all the
works and you have the the premium
that's like six to seven the only people
buying that is key super chaser from
Sonny might be on the driver's seat but
financially Microsoft is doing better
based on the numbers desperate on
console sells I think Sony scared of
next gen you know what you might be on
you know why because field ominous
Spencer we're filled ominous Maximus a
bow on listen listen he's in the mirror
right now and he's throwing his shades
on and is not the cheap ones that I got
on right now he's throwing on those
Louise with Tom butters and he's looking
back he's sitting in his chair and you
know what's playing in his head
and you know in his head with what
versus playing with live is your
heartbeat sounds like sighs be playing a
biggie right there
who shot you guys acting all out of
sorts
looking weird looking smoking in these
streets you guys what's funny is Saudi
running ahead of the curve try to kick
that door open they get sniped and gears
so that's exactly what's going on right
now
these dudes are acting out of sorts you
actin like you haven't been to the table
before like you don't know how to pick
up the fork that boy put that for pure
mr. Sennett they said they already
better pray no one else leaves Phil
getting more no when you talk about
filled how Dominus he is I don't even
remember what you call him these days
but there's maximum expenses okay Phil
Dominus Maximus mr. now I'm like the
weight you talked this man up I'm
thinking he's that statue that you got
back there
listen let me tell you something he is
that apocalypse coming that's exactly
what they see listen you have to really
understand what's going on here
mm-hmm the war may already been won oh
thank you looking at him acting out of
sorts so you're saying he's played chess
and he's already checkmate you know he
did with services now shout out to Josh
for saying you don't really care what's
going on unless they have game pass on
it now you might laugh right but Josh if
they actually launch and they do have a
game pass on it it might be a viable
option well okay okay I remember I told
you before look all I want is Master
Chief on my switch word and it might
happen it might happen but anyway I
think this is a critical misstep if
these individuals decide to drop both
systems which they don't need to do they
must know something right they must know
that either they're not gonna be more
powerful mm-hmm so they have to be cheap
mm-hmm and it can have something as
close enough in power mm-hmm something
has been found out that all of a sudden
now what was first bad is now good
mm-hmm because when Microsoft was going
to do it
it was terrible mmm now they are talking
about doing it and it's supposed to be
good
something was found out and we're gonna
find out later who what's gonna happen
it can Microsoft be at a price point in
a power level that is up staging the
power structure in Sony I really think
something has have for them to change as
you say they got some information for
them to change course like this yes I
jokingly said Google stadia but look at
what Google stadia does the processing
and everything happens on the cloud side
right built in the game to whatever
resolution screen you have right so you
get the set-top box as long as it's you
just set your team you set it to the TV
you've got for the monitor you've got
yeah then there were extra question did
you preorder anything you could beam it
to your cell phone you could beam to
anything so when you want your burst
wars that there's no space in your life
for it nobody likes shout out to see the
John with the true dollar super said
don't forget Sony already bent the knee
for Claire oh my god listen man we'll
see what happens I would [ __ ] on it
today
yeah it's [ __ ] on it today on it I
mean I was surprised by the news news
didn't expect this coming um gonna see
what the pricing the disparity is gonna
be if true but I will say this the
source that is doing this as brought
this attention is fairly reliable cuz he
was a very credible um Sanji he was the
one that uh he was when I first talked
about there would be a switch light
before the initial announcement so this
guy's is legit so this could be
happening y'all we gotta go
I gotta move on but oh I'm gonna
actually solve what I know if you want
to set this one off home did you up pay
attention what's going on with the with
the sales numbers from Microsoft sir I'm
once all ready for this Microsoft has
indicated that they will no longer be
revealing I've subscriber numbers hmm
instead in lieu of that just focusing on
their content and this when you group
mm-hmm you would include their
subscription services I and obviously
when X cloud drops whatever cloud
engagement numbers add a show they
choose to sort of delineate that stuff
so uh and then you know talk it and
that's a throne to be you know once
again go you like really going it out
again damn it's a good subject to he's
going about understand so you're like oh
that's the thing okay again hangouts
look good for a second it looks horrible
alright let's get let's stick with it
you just kind of rehash what you said
see if we don't like I so I don't have
an issue with this because at day Xbox
Live is not what they're more they want
people to get into game past
specifically game past everything into
it so they don't really care about Xbox
I mean that didn't happen um what's a
little strange about it is the sites
that they talked about try one more time
becoming a coming come out I'll kind of
finish off his point and then we'll give
it up to the roundtable yeah man so
pretty much you know marks off is
definitely changing the way they reveal
um you know as far as the sales numbers
and stuff like that and basically you
know they use it a new metric and the
new metric is what they're gonna do to
that you know shareholders has let them
know more about the content and services
revenue
you know as opposed to you know card
console sales and you know stuff like
that so basically what they consider
Xbox content service includes Xbox Live
transactions subscriptions cloud
services and advertising video games and
third party or royalties so um yeah they
basically shift in their focus and it's
going to so we got some bills to pay
okay go take care of it for me take care
so we got a $2.00 super chat by gamer by
choice I don't know if you got that what
the devs did not want multiple consoles
we got a point there you really are are
the ears on that sell video sorry we'll
put your name I can't pronounce stuff
we're gonna move on that though we got a
$20 century from Cedric H a shout-out to
the Lords on this glorious day you know
definitely appreciate everyone that
super chats us you you would not believe
how much that helps and I appreciate the
guy yes Cedric is questions for us to
salute the Cedric Age in the realm but
yeah I'm actually changing the metric
you know this is what's going on right
now this is moving forward you know this
is what they're providing the
shareholders and all that stuff so I
wanted to like us off said bring it to
the table man like what do we think
about this as the cops go by they say
fraud the cows they changed all this
because they don't want to see that
they're selling more games oh and you
know what I hope that is the truth
millions of switches out there let's get
it in our anecdote its first before we
give the Lord a dick man I think they're
low-key finesse a little bit no I you
know it's it's not just them everyone in
every industry has this I think a little
bit it has to do with how they're
choosing to and you know part of me
feels like this is part of a little bit
on Phil Spencer because he's been very
parent that he's like I don't like the
console war all the time and the
majority of these numbers are always
used for console war stuff
no they I'm not saying he did it just
because of that you know I'm saying that
might have been part of the reason
because let's nothing real here there
Connie there get kilt on the hardware
aspect right so they stop showing the
hardware aspect I'm don't think their
numbers are like going really down or
anything like that but you know they
have such a phenomenal game my gears
five and then three million users is
used as a console or aspect in the
instead of it being the celebration
because gears is that good of a game
people was like three million users
that's all fam really like it's Gary
pence they sold it for a dollar what's
going on here like so I think that you
know Microsoft like look we only really
announced this stuff for investors
anyway so let's just stop like I don't
and it's like I said I'm not saying that
they're not hiding something because
they clearly are I would say that sells
and stuff down and that's not
necessarily just a Microsoft issue I
would say that if you look around with
these hype of the next Xbox I'd say
Playstations numbers are going down a
little bit because people generally stop
buying consoles when around the corner
is a new consoles now I feel that I feel
like I get what you saying I mean I want
to give it also to Josh in reference to
this like you know when you hear of a
company changing away as far as the
metrics or you know giving out you know
to the investors does this give you any
warning signs or you feel away about it
or do you say hey you know what they're
focusing on services and growth and this
is what they want to project no I mean
for one it's Microsoft so they're still
making money everywhere right like Xbox
just one one factor there to the
writings been on the wall with what they
wanted to do with this cloud thing it's
gonna be like stadia they want this
thing everywhere so why why put out
numbers about the Xbox when they may be
selling more on PC or eventually people
made just with their iPhones or androids
around yeah like I mean it's basically
gonna be the Netflix of gaming and
Netflix's you don't want you saying that
okay Josh you're not a lot of computers
okay pass the netbook
course not of course not cuz you know I
don't stare at game pass and go hmm what
should I watch that's I mean to me
that's what it's saying because it would
be foolish for them to to try to give
Xbox numbers to the investor and say
like this is what we're going for when
in the reality is they didn't sell those
services that service is where they're
making their money now that's where
their focus needs to be and that's what
the investors need to know so that
they're gonna throw the money at them so
that they can keep get the marketing go
and get it all you know get it all going
and I mean and look what Microsoft seems
to be all about the games we saw at e3
like they bought almost every developer
on the planet so you know like it it it
I don't I think Microsoft is that the
healthiest it's been in a long time
it's just that what would the numbers
were used to seeing as consumers or as
you know people talking about this kind
of stuff we're like wait a minute what
what's what's going on but I mean look I
haven't played my Xbox in a while mmm
and game pass came out at a buck and
guess who's still paying the 15 bucks a
month
yeah and I know I'm not the only one
like oh yeah absolutely good because you
know what something comes out like you
don't have to what you don't have to run
anywhere let it down it's like it's
there like it's there for Mike
not to mention on Twitter when they I'm
more height for what's on game passing
out than games with gold so it's just
like oh I good thing that gang pass does
his games that you kind of had that that
left eye on but he was like nah and they
and then you just heard straight just
ignore it when that comes on game pass
then you straight look at that game cuz
it's like now I can boss move got it
shoo so he said Phil finesse Spencer is
out here wild I waiting for Takashi a
Dave who as a bad well you know unless
is in color I can't
you might be on depict oh you got to get
a get a together from Victor Alice team
I probably butchered your name I
apologize mm-hmm guess five numbers
might have been affected by Xbox Live
going down good show guys he you know he
really is on to something I guess I'll
be we'll see but I got to get kid kicks
a he would've put a ball in this cuz um
the word on the street King is you know
I'm gonna mute my mic you need popcorn
here we go they keep the word these
kings Xbox out here finessing a little
truth they scared phone this is game
pass on my Wow okay so we're not gonna
act like Microsoft doesn't own minecraft
for Minecraft is the highest most
profitable game in the history of video
games are we not gonna act like that
right but so if we want to do numbers
and we want to act numbers you won't
play numbers let's play numbers then if
you really want to do numbers you don't
really want to numbers
alright so every company is not sit
there and do the numbers their best
highlights there their boardroom you
know you have investors and this is
investing time alright when the consoles
is winding down they're trying to get
more people to buy in to re-up
this is the real right we have to re-up
stage here so this is why you're gonna
hear Sony talk about two SKUs why are
they talking about - SKUs
because they want to sell to their
investors we can sell two times as many
as Playstations like do we need it this
time so we sold a hundred mil because
our two hundred million next time this
is their big key so Microsoft right now
switching it up because they they go
into their investors and they're telling
their investors check this out your hold
on second that's purple that's the color
I likes to see oh wow wow shout out to
will marvel with the $50 super chat
another great show laws absolutely the
Oh Lord salute here well listen do me a
favor put a question in the chat um we
don't read it just put a question in
whatever the question is will read it
okay so Lou - Wow thank you brother 100%
much
come and listen listen don't don't don't
get my little overzealous fake-face
right there when you put two dollars and
you put that dollar in whatever you put
in that is that's fantastic and we do
appreciate it
will is in a great space that he's able
to do that and I'm thankful that you're
able to do that sir I do really
appreciate that let's get back to what
everybody's gonna show the company in
the best light this is the real time all
right so there you trying to get your
investors to re-up back into your
company you don't want to invest is
leaving going to somebody else and
invest in and stadia you don't want them
leaving and going to invest in someplace
else
you understand they want to see that
your company is healthy so you're gonna
sell them the best healthy numbers that
you can possibly do right so just like
Josh said you know they're gonna show
them the services the cloud they look
we're moving on from this to this and
this is where we trying to reach
everybody is trying to reach a point
where investors is just throwing money
at them and they don't have to have to
be beholden to the parent company by
telling the parent company we can't do
this so we can't do that because we
don't have the funding right now that
was on your neck he said what wait
aren't they mixing all the subscriptions
together that smells like they try and
hi something King yes they are trying to
hide something they're trying to hide
you know what's a most concerning other
he said Jana stop exactly if you if you
to put it in cuffs a cog read that I
didn't let me tell you they they are
hiding something sir they're hiding that
they have the most consumer friendly
service that you should possibly have
and if you don't have it then you're not
consumer friendly you met you you're
anti consumers they're so consumer
friendly and all of their competitions
anti-consumer for not doing this well
you know listen everybody's going to do
what's in the best what was in the best
interest of their company mm-hmm okay I
can't tell you that I'm understanding
Sony would wish they would have a
service of this magnitude to go along
with all those systems that they have
out there understand if they did have a
service that will
with all those things could you imagine
how dominant they would be but you don't
get both
all right so both of them are both
looking to get both mm-hmm you have to
understand if Microsoft is switching up
the narrative they're switching up the
words they're switching up the verbiage
it's not for you that verbiage is being
switched up for the investor so I have a
guy too sitting on the fence and I need
his 500 million to invest in my company
he's sitting on the fence and he says
let me see your books let me see your
numbers I cook the books the best tell
me I'm gonna come in here with weak
numbers all year we sold 31 million and
what did your competition so all they
sold 100 marketing 101 yes listen let's
stop acting like we're in here putting
in stock from these companies your games
do so I had a game that you like I'm
gonna go buy Zelda I don't have no
[ __ ] Nintendo so if they fold them
all I still got Zelda it is interesting
you know what this information came out
to me just showed like the complete
focus toward services this is the route
they're going they're banking all they
put me all the eggs in a basket you know
and like you said I think addicts said
it's it's they at this point this is an
Aaron acquisition mode right there in
you know engagement subscription mode
getting everybody and under the Sun
in-game pass and I think they are
willing to take on the hit like for
example like using gears as a jumping
for a springboard to say look it's
high-quality games you jump in you know
we give the first two months for a
dollar but once you locked in like Josh
is saying how many of us really
unsubscribe you know they're counting on
most people to stay in the ecosystem you
know as they prep for like a cloud
services and stuff then they got going
but you know for next gen you were
saying Eric it's not even just that like
people just look at you know they're the
simplistic creatures they just look at
one aspect of it you know people that
got gang passed for 9.99 that doesn't
have gold so what they buy stuff on they
download something on guinea pass oh I
need go to play this online all right
I'll get the the $9.99 for for Xbox Live
or the $14.99 for for both of them you
know also if they're gaming on Xbox
people act like no one buys games you
know you you get people into your
ecosystem with game pass people buy the
games on game pass which leads to money
people buy games off a game pass which
leads to money people will subscribe to
more subscription services which leads
to money yeah which is this is what
they're banking on I want to shout out
Wilma that he did put a question in do
you think at some point game pass will
show up on switch I mean I I am I think
so I think that is their goal if it's up
to Microsoft they want game pass
everywhere this is I think breaking
their their horse or now that's like
theme I would have I think it definitely
will when they feel like game pass is on
the pillar that they can make it on it
like I feel like right now they know gay
pastors pop and gay pastor's heart but I
don't know if they're willing to devalue
their brand that much until they feel
like game Pass is to a point where they
know they're gonna make money everywhere
yeah look at it I don't think they care
about the devaluing well I feel like if
they if they it would have been implied
from the start like but play baseless
they have been keeping game pass off a
switch for a reason well I think it's
about keeping off I think that the
rumors from what we heard was that they
were in talks early doing something we
don't know what it is but it definitely
gonna so maybe it's a situation where
Nintendo will differ instruction
whatever it's just not ready it's gonna
take one with a minute we don't know
what it is but we do know there's some
level of communication cuz obviously
they're playing super nice we're seeing
Ori over there we see a cup head over
there like both are playing super friend
game right now they don't like it each
other's posts that sounds like a you
know they like they playing it real nice
so it to me it's only a matter of time
before something happens and we'll see
if it's game pass you knows I don't I
just think that they want game has to be
at a certain level before they start
extending it to other platforms case you
know I'm saying that maybe like they
want it to have like be able to show
okay that we're making five million
subscribers without breaking a sweat on
Xbox right imagine what we could do on
the switch you
absolutely but then in you know
Microsoft defense like you know they tow
got to get to that level of
infrastructure where it needs to be for
this thing to work you know my rap is
there with the Xbox Live okay okay
I think the X cloud is the catalyst I
think once that is established and that
is running correctly to the point that
isn't necessary you see you just can't
take a game pass and just throw it on a
switch right all right so you have to
have that X cloud that's powering that
behind it that can funnel those games
over so they're not actually playing the
games that there's stream in the games
you see so eat whatever the device is
once that X cloud with that game pass is
on your device and that's what makes
your device game pass viable so I think
actually what Microsoft is doing is the
Xbox itself is a testbed right and once
the testbed is already once they build
that foundation they're gonna leapfrog
from Mirror to wherever they're going to
go to wherever to get those of those
services up where stadia is they don't
need a testbed
they are their own tests but that Google
stripping best a testbed already I think
sooner or later X clouds can eventually
come on like a little flash drive or
thumb drive and it's gonna be like you
know you could play these and they're
gonna have like their own hub of game
paths like that's gonna be their number
one seller like that's what they're
gonna push for X cloud it's like we have
all the X cloud stuff right there and
its own hub I kind of like what they
have on PC right now or just shows game
pass and all the games already passed
and break they have it on Xbox you don't
you're gonna load up X cloud and it's
gonna be like you could play what you
have or you could subscribe to this
service and play what's on game pads I
mean I'm a firm believer that game pass
ultimate will probably have X cloud in
some form of fashion you know including
that those two will be kind of married
together but I think I think it's gonna
be the highlight of it I think it'll be
the office around it yeah I think the
premium a119 mark yeah yeah so that's
pretty much what I got on this look we
went kind of lone with that we got one
when I want to get out of here but
that's what I got on that I want to move
on
last thing I'll touch on it you know it
quickly as possible which is e3 so it's
a lot going on man with the ESA you know
pretty much in their vision and what
they want it to be so there's a new
proposal going on right now you know to
a lot of these guys on the board and
basically e3 vision as they say on the
star is gonna be a fan media and
influential influence our festival you
know I'm saying so they say they want to
have the biggest fans top video game
companies leading outlets celebrities
and our influence and athletes so
they're saying it's changing so here's
the thing that they're saying what's new
newly conceived design short floor
digital III experience industry and
media will have their own day more
players and fans PRS I hear clapping I
hear you clap trillion baby pure
opportunities for companies to enhance
brands opportunities more market
directly to players celebrity engagement
program at Indy app scheduling so I
guess they're trying to get those lines
down you know saying Q entertainment to
a life aligned engagement while you
waiting on the line paid media
partnerships and then photo ops and
video game tournaments so a lot of this
news has been disseminated yeah that
look you think that can save you through
it's been especially like the biggest
issue people have of e3 the media
they're like why you letting these no
names in here take it on my time like
giving them a whole day I think will
solve that like you get in here but you
know people don't realize how much media
there is either you still go they still
gonna be waiting a long time but you
won't have Bob and Ross that's in front
of you they bought the pass and just
showed up and they take you tension they
take your two spots are taking 20 to 30
minutes ago time but now now you just
got done what's that what I do that
that's what my Gina keep mispronouncing
his name
that's the McGregor Gary alligator
that's in front you don't got a Bob and
Ross you just got Dustin like now it's
it's it's not been all well received
anything there's been a lot of pushback
you know some people feel you know they
don't
the whole paid media influencer thing
involved what exactly is that Intel
wouldn't it again it says the EA ESA
might be pursuing advertising deals with
media outlet it clearly states it
intends to create page we will see like
a big billboard by GN well they said
well put it this there's a show out
right now from CNBC shot the whole
Glory's got a good video on this and
kind of super Jenna take every phone
please super chat from JD game I can't
wait to go to e3 to 2020 hoping to get
those fan fest tickets I am too right
there with you what's the best place to
eat showroom floor or outside food all
day long you go to the showroom floor
you're gonna overpay for stuff that is
way better if you would just went
outside go don't waste your time JD game
but hopefully that you you know we see
you out at e3 and listen if you don't
get game fan fest tickets make sure
whatever they're doing now it sounds
like they're doing some really good
stuff make sure you book early make sure
that you set yourself up properly and
make sure you have a thorough plan going
through all the way to fan fest I mean
you get so here's the thing adequate
which people upset you know again
creating these paid media part media
partnerships with major outlets to
increase their gulf but people have the
main issue says that it enables the esa
to control the content and the messaging
and it was found out there's a show
called on CNBC protect impact that was
sponsored by the ESA that had a little
influence and a little tentacles in so
anyway let me give this to josh you know
obviously me and you met at e3
you know III is kind of you know
important to us so what do you feel
about these proposed changes nothing is
finalized yet but these are things they
are proposing for e3 2020 look I had to
walk seven miles everyday between
meetings there's a loss walk the less
people that are there in my way the
better I think like you know giving the
media whole day to themselves I think
that will fix a lot of things though I
don't know about this you know paid
promotion stuff that's a little bit too
much for me but if es a problem
money it's probably with this about like
probably about to lose millions off this
long sue they got to get that money back
I guess mm-hmm so good good - yeah so
you you are you with all the aspects
that they're mentioning yeah if I'm
gonna be honest I don't even really care
all that much like it's not even like if
I can get there make my connections do
my networking get the content I need um
I'm finally that like it you know like
at this point it's more about it's gonna
be more about hanging out with like
hanging out with the community as a
whole and and working my face off during
the day like that's that's what it is
for me so as long as that can still take
place
I'm I'm down now if media is going to be
limited because mm it's going to be to
these you know to the paid outlets that
they're you know there's a good point
like I like that that that's I'm not
okay with that
yeah absolutely absolutely Atticus he
chirping man yeah I mean III itself you
guys know how I feel about e3 e3 it's
it's the networking that's all there's a
lot of people think that III is about
games it's about talking about it's not
really about playing games because the
lines are six hours long you go away six
hours I can literally watch too Lord of
the Rings movies park to play a game at
e3 so you know it's about that network
working it's about time now they talk
about an aptitude you'll jump in and are
they going to so needn't say yeah that's
what they talking you talk about that
that's gonna crash because everyone's
last day I guess what I'm about to say
when I get what is my term but continue
what I have to like you know that they
could show me all the the writing on a
paper all they want I need to see it in
action I need to see what they keep what
they don't keep you know they obviously
put this out there to see the reaction
for the community to see what they can
and cannot get away from so let's see
Lord
sovereign are all this news where do you
stand are you for are you against these
proposed ESA changes I mean everything
that has to do with you know
so properly King bear yeah okay
so you know you damned if you do damned
if you don't everybody want to complain
about always this and I was that okay so
you media dudes you get your day all
right
even if is a day of his two days you get
your day without the the people the
peasants bothering you right okay fine
see everybody thinks and shout out the
judge for saying this everybody thinks
that we're out there having this
glorious time you know we're out there
working like he said he walked seven
miles from A to point B our legs are
throbbing we're getting home our feet is
busted we're doing this to get it so I
used to exercise it's so bad that would
you go with the video it's so bad that
when you go to this event you sitting in
the hotel you got a really look like
what do I really need to take to this
thing when I don't need it this is
monumental we got to solve a video right
now yeah hold on let's all get it today
I'm willing to bet that that apocalypse
back there fixes internet what my thing
is like I said the spookiest thing about
this is those partnerships with without
like
really like you really like and the
funny thing is this past week where I
was listening to podcast unlocked right
no mention of this story whatsoever mmm
if you if you look at the big outlets
and their podcasts there is no mention
of this and and anything negative about
it meaning that all of them know about
this they all about this okay Big
Brother they go get that access no for
them they are a hundred percent in on
this and that is a spooky thing anytime
you sell yourself to the devil in order
to get coverage I'm not about that
that's one I that that's super spooky
I'm looking for the back sir and I get
that I get I get I mean us being a small
outlet if somebody drops the bag a
couple peas back the marketing manager I
will never let you sell out for you but
nice must be happy 7 you just gonna have
to hold that I would tell you sit back
and I'm gonna make sure that you have a
whole avatar in Final Fantasy 7 for that
bag that's the bad the other thing that
bothers me is this all this stuff about
getting no celebrities in there like
celebrities unless they're really gamers
and I think that number is you know few
and far between it's obvious how
disingenuous they haha why they don't
want to be there I don't want to see Zac
Effron a big and claim splitter so Aaron
judge larren just really plays with it
so no doubt little a breeze can't be up
there fraud
Marren you don't wait you know what
because they're actors and they don't
even act well when they try problems
with this whole thing about okay so
while you're waiting in line in the
queue they're gonna try to entertain you
while you're a miserable stranding
online I'd be more entertained standing
in line if like Kevin Hart was crying so
always but I have to hit you with he
gotta get you I got a reason why I gotta
get you when we was at fan fest and the
sillas was out they didn't the first
time not the third time the fourth time
in the fifth time mm-hmm
those sailors was out there dance I'm
told by the first time we saw the sail
is dancing how was it they were singing
this song it was entertaining us but we
was on a line right I had dudes out
there paid for dudes to dance and sing
first and you know what I'm about how
about all of that now if you want to pay
celebrities to get up there and the
platers get paid a celebrity you know
what it is deeply has become boring mmm
all right I want you to turn it into
Disney World I want to walk and I want
to be Wow I'm gonna be amazing
I wanna be I don't want to look at my
app and say I have a 3:30 appointment to
ride a dinosaur Paul I want to be there
you know because Zac Efron is my wingman
and I want to and people may disagree
I'd rather the booth babes come back
you see that's the only time to get them
to smile you see the booth babes take a
page they're coming back I think they're
coming back
but for them to control this narrative
right don't we think that they're
supposed to right now when they're under
the bus what would you do like you you
you could lose it all and so this does
feel like desperation yes Maria a
Maricopa it try to fix things after you
know dropping everybody's little
security numbers online right so
everybody has been saying III has been
failing right right what way to fix it
they looked at everybody's list of
problems as media we was tired of being
around the commoner right and as we were
sick and tired of being on this line and
we had to skip the line we had to show
up
you know like in okay they had a date
how many times did you see a guy on line
and he really wanted to be there but his
girlfriend was with him and she was like
I really want going here in the face
like oh it's right so you didn't want to
have to deal with that you wanted to go
get you your video go get your interview
get the footage and move on right so
let's say you've got your two days to do
that that shuts up the media dudes now
right now they only say one day okay so
one day what about that they get a day
before you had no two hours yeah that's
correct okay okay but good you got this
now right now for those people that are
Tagalongs
with a significant other they actually
can see celebrities right actually have
something else to focus on if they're
not gamers so remember I think sales
probably took a dip right right so now
don't the sales go up if there's
promised celebrity's line of you
basically it becomes a consumer show
where they're gonna they have already a
lot they say they're gonna lot another
ten
more of the gamer pass tickets I guess
so basically it become like a festival
event like yo I'm coming there as a fan
to go see you know this whole Disney
World kind of let me jump in this is
good oh here's the day you know right
now certain proposal none of this is
finalized but they definitely are
changing III is changing in some way I'm
which solved or I don't know about this
paid influencer thing that rubs me the
wrong way if certain outlets is gonna
get you know only know to access and
kind of spin things I don't know how I
feel about yes a sponsoring the show
unless it I launch podcast we could talk
about you wanna holler you will put your
logo let me stop it anyway your jokes
aside like that part I don't know um
addict I don't know about that app
because I remember we were there one
time because all the people just think
about this when Sony was doing it for
Sony's experience and you wanted to play
than has never worked it Detroit is a
bad example given a cloud do you Sony
all I'm saying is if that was just Sony
Games and the entire convention is
trying to book at 11:00 o'clock
appointment to play Detroit to human in
spite of it what's gonna happen with the
entire convention west about what game
they got as a cloud now you know well we
see which leads me to but I don't we go
get in the ESA is infrastructure in a
minute but anyway here's my thing this
is this is important to me you're like
III y'all know like I got the history
with this day like this as a gamer it's
the Super Bowl you know they're like
it's the mecca you gotta go to you gotta
say that you did it you were baptized
you know saying you've been you know so
it's you know a lot of a lot of people I
met there I'm responsible a lot of
friendships I gained theirs because of
three so you know with this we see that
the major publishers opposed to pulling
out all right you see the EAS doing the
own thing Microsoft say they own theater
Sony didn't even go last year you know
say it's definitely changing and we
can't for it games come sounding like
that new way so that all these things
are on III s neck in my opinion right so
they have to do something
here's my issues off and I gotta get to
it I just don't like how we talk they
talk about all this new stuff
how did not talk about all this
information that got lost I mean they
got like y'all just say had the biggest
breach of information by influences and
media and there's no plan to regain the
trust there's an investigation going on
sir talk about that at this time not
even offering a plan about what like
they've lost so much trust with
everyone's information leaking in the
street and you got the nerve to be
talking about how hot is gonna be next
year when you come back I think Kings
onto something I think I think it really
is it's legal issues they're not allowed
to really talk about that or you can't
really touch stuff like that
it should be at least a statement saying
they have not even mistreatments I'm
just saying that we know cuz they want a
lawyers are like don't about we got an
email you got the email the dead bodies
in the corner don't look at in the
listen bro you can't tell these could be
the people that you lost a information
to black no but next year when you sign
up there we gonna have yours
we got cobia be like [ __ ] like no Joe
Jon Josh let me ask you a question today
you know obviously someone such as
yourself now what wouldn't this was
leaked did you ever for once think that
you weren't going to e3 the following
year III did consider it for a second
yeah
and then you realized that oh man it's
III I kind of have to get but think
about how many people are not gonna say
they'd like you I'm never trusting them
again I'm never going back think about
the your people people that I ain't goin
didn't really have to go in the first
place good point
you don't ever lead off a conversation
with your wrongs
all right you lead the conversation off
with your powerpoints mm-hmm great and
they will address the wrongs that
particular time but you know first they
gotta tell you what new rods that they
put inside they gotta tell you that they
do have the Pokemon exhibit me I'll tell
you that this stuff is available for you
a new to can see the lifelike resi Fassa
made in the crowd the same time they're
secretly emailing all these people
that's apologize but they're being sued
and it can't address that we can't talk
about that right now
this matter is clear we're gonna tell
you the new safety precautions that we
got with the azure cloud what its gonna
be it's like we can't talk about that
but when this is cleared you could read
anything that was made public but that's
about all this I feel away about that
like I said they're in a lot of trouble
and they got a national reason I
guarantee you they know you guys nation
may be right all I'm saying is until
they get that situation resolved they
cannot expect you know a lot of these
game devs influences to be like yes I'm
coming back to the e3 is on notice right
now like that's all I'm saying so we'll
all this lot time in the morning on your
morals don't you worry about me sir the
things the Lord's will do to sellout
sellout she heard was they put new stuff
in the yard okay I want the media
couldn't is they don't want his media
credentials
how
anyway let's get out of here man so that
is it's a new ILP poll with the latest
rumors regarding a PS 5 in PS 5 probe
skew launching simultaneously do you
think a dual console strategy is the
correct approach by Sony heading into
the next gen the choices are no confuses
the market keep that same energy with
Lockhart and etic odd that was announced
B yes give PlayStation gamers options
and price and power or C Auto can set a
real powerhouse the switch pro is an app
that is the truth those are the
questions those are choices please Rock
the Vote when it goes up on ILP later on
Twitter Lord and 60 for Josh an absolute
pleasure to have you in the realm where
can I find people find you what you got
going on sir it's n64 Josh everywhere
Twitter Facebook snapchat farmers only
[Laughter]
[Music]
podcast music is until today yeah check
out the book on Amazon
no doubt so where's the podcast so let
the people know when is the podcast is
every well it's usually Mondays but it's
gonna be Tuesdays the next two weeks
live at wish on TV slash n64 Josh around
7:00 p.m. Pacific Standard Time and you
can find it after the fact on YouTube
and iTunes Google Play stitcher Spotify
no absolute pleasure to have you around
man good thanks for having me guys the
plastic your last mad format absolute
pleasure meeting you like I said I was
with the ghost plane and we was linking
it up I was like I like to do he's guy
he's very insightful we got to do it man
we got to work together would do
something so salute to Josh in the
building you already know that'd you
right now I had cake is a thing he's a
fair guy
that's what's up so Lord adequate if my
people find you man I don't know I might
have to go on a farmers only you can
follow me on Twitter at Lord addict I'll
pee you can i definitely check out my my
borderlands 2 review on youtube gaming
at it you can also you know that for
those of you that like reading for some
reason your lives i'll be up here
shortly at us at the Lords of gaming net
that's right play you know I don't know
what a you know really think our guest
Joshua come on he was a great guest I'm
gonna put his Twitter and in the chat so
you can go follow him show us some love
definitely appreciate everyone that
showed up and all the super chats uh I
definitely appreciate all that -
absolutely Louis off back in the
building some technical difficulty oh I
can go fresh off when you had to cam on
you were silky the Lord's each I tell
you some tell me my stuff on my stuff I
you go see that green moistures back in
the bushes bad gonna receive you had
devices you put the camera on it was
like yes it's over now come and do
everybody you know what to catch me
that's it screaming damn it oh yeah go
Supremes in a building job that's always
with me that day when I saw you go
supreme in a chat yes salute salute
yo Lord King what's going on sir let me
tell you something first of all I want
to thank you so much for being here Josh
I didn't get a chance to meet you at e3
but I had to hear it for go supreme the
whole time when we
that's my wingman he's driving in the
Corvette he's telling me man you me Josh
know them drinks is flowing we had like
it was late and to know that he's a
fellow amiibo collector he's a Nintendo
lover but most of all so your custom
cabinet maker so you go know why your
friend check it out you see the statue
in this room in the back
I go to Lourdes a game and dotnet right
now you can follow me at King David OTW
on Twitter um that's the only place you
can follow me but we have you know more
statues like that and other statues that
you see all around on every Thursday you
know a king um king of the statues um
listen guys you know we joke we play
around on this but everybody that's here
everybody that supports even if you
don't support you as far as financially
you're supporting by being here and I do
appreciate each and every last one of
you guys the jokes is fantastic and I I
know I joke around but I read it I may
not mention it out loud but I read it um
thank you for coming through and I do
appreciate everybody that's here no
doubt man saluted to chat today
everybody was on fire again you already
know hit them likes notification shared
it thing out y'all show everything of
you enjoy the content please share this
out as much as possible spread the word
trying to do things on the Lord's Day
and you already know we got the Lords of
gaming dotnet articles up there like
King said king of the statues all that
good stuff if you want dimensions you
want more information on the statute
please check that out is some great
stuff and great great writers right now
man we got a lot of things in Pocket
Lord my child the Lord Josh North dizzy
please said Lord is your love man he's
definitely in his recovery mode you know
and like I said if you just said them
some cool words manages to get his
spirit up we would appreciate that of
course Lord Frey
Josh reading on Hector macho everybody
senado and of course the stream team I
see an old school styling in MJ the boss
just woke up now jumping in the chat
late late hangover hangover boy frat
party and a new friend
salute LJ doe boss but he just waking up
catcher that's late but up you could
catch him and the entire stream team
hosted by PD lost and they have a
roundtable with the stream team that is
on Monday nights at 9:00 it's very cool
if you're interested in streaming
learning about it how to get started
please check those guys out man I can't
say enough about them you're doing well
king of statues up and of course if you
want that destiny talk that Luther
shooter taught me and my man he bounces
every Friday we're up there talking on
the last word fantastic show you get to
see me at him go at it and he proved
that he's wrong all the time
no just joking but all jokes aside
please check that out that's all I got
if anybody's got anything else know
football is long gone everybody enjoy
your Sunday we are out peace